hello hello it's the hp podcast it's
friday baby
may 8th
we are joined by bobby lee and kalila
uh so happy to have him in the
studio
already having a good time
thank you guys for being here thanks for
having us so excited
now bobby before you begin i need to
thank my sponsor so i just need you to
be i need to be cool for like
20 seconds okay
okay cool thanks thank you to uh mitt
mobile
if saving more and spending less is one
of your top goals for 2022
is it okay so far
why are you still paying insane amounts
of money every month for wireless
you're staring at me very intently
is this going okay
switching to mint mobile is the easiest
way to save this year
as the first company to sell premium
wireless service on it okay it could be
faster
the company you sell premium wireless
service online only mobile lets you
maximize your savings with plans
starting at just 15 bucks a month
mint mobile dan you love mint mobile dan
it's the same thing as all the big boys
it's super cheap it's 15 bucks a month
uh it's a no brainer you can use your
own phone with any mint mobile plan
sweating bro
just
as long get through it it's usually not
this long
use your own phone with any mobile plan
and keep your phone number along with
all your existing contacts
with mint mobile choose the amount of
monthly data that's right for you and
stop paying for data that you never use
to get your new wireless payment for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mipmobile.com afterdark that's
mintmobile.com cut your wireless bill to
15 bucks a month that meant mobile.com
slash after
all right
that was like yeah
i mean so we usually do those
pre-bumpers but that one's a long damn
it's gotta be easier than brian reynolds
i'll tell you that right now
yeah right
hold on we don't he owns that thing
right yeah
what what what is he doing with the
i mean i love mobile i love it too
that being said what the [ __ ] are you
doing ryan reynolds in the mobile game
well because i think he's just trying to
generate more income
he's not rich enough i don't know i
don't know how much he is i'll tell you
right now how much he is how much is how
much is he i mean he's in every movie
now yeah yeah 150 million
that's pretty good it's not bad but okay
you know it's capitalism more money
you know more money more money how are
you guys good
thanks for being here so i just want to
before i forget because we're talking
about bottoms before the show okay yeah
go ahead and so you
what just to be clear i was just
explaining what happened and how
apologetic i was i want to bring that
part off because i want to get well i
just don't want people to think that we
were having this whole in-depth
conversation about bottoms about bottom
of the muffins
yeah and how the top of the muffins is
the best part yeah
we were talking about power bottoms
right you identified
no i don't identify with being a power
bottle i'm just saying that if i'm on
the bottom i'm not powering up
because you're on top you do the work
yeah no i feel that so i'm not gonna go
up but so i have a question yeah and
guys please this is a simple pursuit of
knowledge and bobby's got me going
can a power bottom be on top
what how would you
be top no the answer is within the
question no oh because i didn't i
thought
so is a power bottom not simply a
receiver or someone who is on the bottom
no power
dan says i'm right
power bottom could be on top yes yeah
wow
that works how does that work go ahead
because the bottom is just the receiver
so they could be you know you could be
like cowboy or like anything
[Music]
the power bot they can ride
with vigor
all participants are worthy and
respectful and we love them all if
you're on top or bottom there this is
beautiful right right
holes or genitals that's fine too that's
that's you just a block of flesh
it's a cube of flesh
we love them as well but if you and i
weren't on island power cube and a year
went by we're gonna have make love or i
don't know how long would it take
longer
five years
longer
a decade do you think
who wouldn't initially
but let's get to the hype yeah the
hypothetical would you initiate or would
you even that's what i'm saying i think
we would never no because no one we're
so lazy
i think i'd rather put my dick no and no
offense bobby i love you i'd rather put
i'd rather [ __ ] the sand that's what he
does
a
wait how does that work i did it one
time when i was like what are you trying
to grow a tree
tree no i just wanted to see what would
make love to the
to the earth and how did it feel like i
was making love to god
oh so so it was good yeah it was pretty
good hey
hello sorry guys hold on i got to take
this okay
hey what clock game it's friday baby
it's friday baby
this is why gabe he calls me every
friday
happy friday uh white club gabe do you
know bobby lee and kalila they're here
they're our guests today
what's going on my brother
what's going on it's friday baby where
are you right now
i'm at menchie's having some
yogurt okay
it's friday baby [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
me [ __ ] yeah
horse [ __ ] energy eh first [ __ ] energy
baby
i'm excited [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] baby
out of the weekend you want to say
something that white clock gabe he's
he's our friend
hey why is it white clark
it's a white claw the drink yeah yeah
white claw gabe white clog
claw you know white claw you're not good
the white claw yeah white claw
game yeah
what's up
what's going on my brother what's up
it's friday baby
are you filipino claw
filipino yeah
oh kala too right
i can i know the difference between you
because you
can you tell the difference between all
asian people generally i mean he's
definitely filipino i do and and do you
see
could you line up and forgive my
ignorance i just really a pursuit of
knowledge here please but like if you
take a japanese person a korean person
a filipino per a chinese you could you
could identify them i can pick out
filipinos from a mile away yeah there's
like certain like
yeah but
i can probably do korean japanese pretty
well yeah you have to it's just a matter
of like where you're what you've been
around and what you recognize like
yeah from living in israel i can
immediately tell israelis obviously uh
russia no oh really oh yeah it's like a
russian guy and a jewish person would
you be good
is there a test that you do or just
visually no you can't pull down your
pants
oh my god
[Music]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] there's like there's this
difference there's some
american russian
can you tell the caucasian apart
british
oh hell yeah no yeah i could definitely
tell
i could definitely tell caucasians apart
that's true wait wait wait white claw
you could tell a british guy between an
american guy without talking
it depends on who what region you're
from you can talk original english or
american english oh
hey what kind of yogurt are you eating
today there uh gabe i'm having chocolate
just straight chocolate right there
straight chocolate my boy
it's friday it's straight chocolate day
my dude
all right
so yeah do you guys want to ask anything
a gay before we sign off yeah yeah um
are you married can i ask that yes
yeah yeah white claw are you married
for women no no you're not married no no
okay are you seeing anybody
not right now i'm taking expectations of
women that want to go out with me i
gotta interview to see if they're right
for me oh i see oh god
we all do it yeah yeah yeah yeah
i mean let me ask you something when
you're can i ask him a person what do
you say he ask him he's just a guy right
there all right
i'm not his handler when you when you
make love to a woman do you go
[ __ ] yeah
that is a good question that's a good
question yeah yeah
okay [ __ ] yeah i get to learn
then i'll go do my [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
okay like when you're gonna be a
gentleman first oh yeah but being a
gentleman first and then once she gets
to know me then i can go [ __ ] yeah baby
uncomfortable
[Laughter]
all right white club well thanks for
calling in gabe always nice to hear from
you
i hope you have a good weekend you got
any good plans this weekend or no
it's mother's day probably have brunch
every saturday have a fight and then do
some drinking
do some drinking and watching the fight
and [ __ ] the cigar
as usual [ __ ] they [ __ ] yeah baby
that sounds good
all right well you have a good time and
uh wish all the mothers in your life uh
lots of love for me okay
all right
happy mother's out there to all the moms
[ __ ] in my bed [ __ ] my butt [ __ ]
wait what are you saying [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
in my butt [ __ ] your butt [ __ ] yeah i
like it
all right you take care buddy appreciate
you all right
how's cameo going yeah cameo is going
good
white collar is doing good that's good
white cloth gabe on cameo we'd like to
give him a shout out right yeah yeah you
guys can get a actually a mother's day
shout out from white club gabe could be
a good
yeah
all right
[Laughter]
[ __ ] baby yeah [ __ ] it all right you
take care of gabe you have a great
weekend okay all right love you buddy
all right bye bye bye bye
wow
wow yeah and i mean
we get a
we get graced by white claw gabe every
friday yeah he was he's a he's a tick
tock character
we found him on tick tock
because he he went viral for you know
obvious reasons his antics uh he's
hilarious so now he he gave famous for
going it's friday baby oh and so now he
calls in every friday thank you thank
you for doing that we don't have a lot
of filipino representation oh there you
go
he's the biggest one there is right now
in america
koreans we have stephen yoon and you
have a white claw
congratulations babe
so uh wait hold on you actually have
bella porch yes bella porch oh she's
huge yeah she's
yeah
great dude yeah i love both of them
um i saw a photo of you i don't know
what it was but it was of your ass or
whatever and there was not a cellulite
yeah i'm fat as [ __ ] dude i'm huge i
mean take a look at me i'm just a
monster it's kind of it's just it's hard
this angle is not good i mean there's no
space for me and it's just honestly i'm
just i'm tired of being myself man yeah
i'm ready to ch
what
i don't know i'm being a hyperbolic yeah
yeah i didn't mean to alarm you yeah no
i just um but i liked it
oh yeah
well the thing about that picture yeah
it was a photo shoot for teddy fresh
where the back of my pants was like
burned off yeah and the thing about it
uh
is
it's funny yeah i like that thank you
but i was kind of startled by how the
ass
was like a perfect plus sign like the
four corner states
like there was just no structure it was
like the
first aid sign you know
yeah not good wait you know surprisingly
for a 50 year old man he has no
cellulite and it
enrages me to no one because i have a
lot are you supple
i just don't have any no matter how much
weight i get there's nothing wrong with
cellulite i don't know it doesn't bother
me it is a lot i count them uh-huh
currently
116.
say what they little 16 little holes oh
you count them yeah i count them
i feel like it really
makes uh women insecure right yeah like
i hate it i i mean even i have yeah some
what's the problem with you i don't know
well it's natural i mean even even young
like
when you're young you have it you sit
down your skin puckers up and [ __ ] right
yeah i mean what can you do about
cellulite it's just what you've been
told like yeah we all we're all supposed
to look perfect stretch marks things
like that which i had stretch marks when
i was like 16. yeah i i have something
here like from even before the
pregnancies i really don't know from
what probably from just growing up yeah
it's like the most natural do you
upstream you know your skin is perfect
yes
but it's
honest i mean i don't know how you feel
about touching a man's skin
i'll touch you touch my skin how soft it
is just i don't want to brag but oh my
goodness
holy [ __ ]
but his back skin is does that do
anything for you that's softness it
really does because he hardly has any um
leg hair either he just has weird like
patching genitals
my penis is like sandpaper it's very
rough
but but the rest of my body is very so
what do you do to that poor thing
yeah this is callous dude you know yeah
callous yeah
yeah i know he's very full of like
turgor like tightness he's just
overwhelmed like his back you can't even
pinch it because it's just very tight
really yeah the skin is wow you're
blessed you have a cure you're blessed
does your penis lean to a certain
direction
can i ask that or not sure weird no you
can ask me anything yeah no my penis
has a slight upward curve very slight
but mostly straight i've been with a guy
who had a downward curve and i remember
getting there seeing it and then just
leaving because oh it was that
intimidating to you yeah because it was
really big and really hooked downwards
and and i remember like apologizing
because i was like i just really know
you couldn't even engage with it
no and then he was like you know you
wouldn't be the first and i felt really
bad
this guy drops trial and people just
leave
it's it's just more like i don't i
wouldn't know what to do with something
hooked down it was like a serious
hookage yeah it was we're talking like
neither left nor right okay interesting
just down and it was big you say huge so
you were just like no thanks well you
yeah politely if it's hooked out just
do it this way
why weren't you there to coach me then i
know you back then
you would figure it out even if i like
saw a woman's vagina it was shaped a
little weird but it what if it was like
a 90 degree just straight fish hook
oh
but it wasn't that bad
not that bad but i couldn't imagine
i couldn't imagine enjoying it in any
way i didn't even know how to really
like that's kind of i feel like that's
that's pretty interesting that you had
before you had the presence of mind to
just say no
yeah and you know we still had nice
chats after that i was just very like no
thanks that i'm not the person for the
job and the first time you saw bobby's
penis
i was thrilled
oh really yeah that's [ __ ] that's
beautiful yeah it had you know it was
neopolitan ice cream had three colors so
i'm really into tri-color things
three colors
it's like what she's counting is the
ring
what brain
what i'm saying is you know the stem
for me i don't know if i've never seen
yours but like mine has a like a little
ring around it like a little you sure
that's not like a worm infection
no no no no
you have a discoloration ring around
it's like a little ring around it it's
not like it kind of looks like you know
what it looks like it looks like you
know that ring from lord of the rings
there's like a little
fish
yeah right it glows what you know
when you burn it yeah but
yeah but like there is a definite ring
and so the ring my ring
is dark like a dark purple and the rest
of it's kind of a tan
okay right and then the because of the
tip of my penis is a little pink
she thinks there's
a palette so you like that yeah and also
like he had done this thing you know he
always does a small penis thing on he's
like oh my dick's so small my dick's so
small so when i finally saw it it was
far from that's the wisdom right thank
you you go it's small it's small it's
small right oh i can't and then when
it's like just normal yeah they're like
bingo baby yeah because they're smart
one thing right but then when they see
that oh it's relatively normal you know
they say in sales uh
under promise over deliver
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i do that with all my life
i love that yeah i think it works with
everything in life yeah even when i'm
like even when i tell people
you know
uh
like if people don't know what like back
in the day i didn't know i did stand up
and they were at from work okay
at a job and you know they go come see
my show i'm okay and then i just kind of
do better than they thought smile yes
that's my part
like if somebody's like oh yeah i'm the
best or
yeah speaks like highly of themselves
i'm like red flags
not funny something's wrong here yeah
yeah like there are comics that do that
you only need to yeah name someone
brendan schwab
i'm a beast
wait we can't talk about it yeah we can
talk about it
if you
no i would love to talk about what why
don't you want to talk about brendan
schwab
but you're down no no so
uh brendan schaub
well here's what i'll say about brendan
schwab schwab schwab oh
[Laughter]
i call him a schwab because he looks
like a uh
a schwa you know like is that they call
those schwabs in the air yeah uh swab
okay
you gently do it but this is on you this
is on you okay so brendan here's the
voice on you and that's it he's a
comedian
that you have a podcast with uh
two other very funny ladies called
love all three of you guys my heart's
beating because i want to be delicate
about this 100 okay yes shred tread
lightly i will tread lightly so you guys
were doing a show and you said that
someone you guys knew
was trying to pick hold on you don't
want to even say this is just well just
correct me where i'm wrong we don't need
to stress you guys how it it's going to
distress him because
okay go ahead ethan
you okay bobby
[Laughter]
so you guys said yeah this guy brendan
schwab you alluded to it you said his
initials was bs everybody now knows it's
him right um well the first time that we
had talked you know it was
um it was a story about someone who had
hit on me seven years ago it was a story
about some but we never said his name
during the first show you guys were
together seven years ago yes we've been
together nine
okay playboy
pound it for that [ __ ] tri-colored
[ __ ] but man when is your 10-year
anniversary next year next year okay uh
ours is coming up i was like oh my god
[Laughter]
with no intention other than to just
tell a story about a funny story
interesting just to get a good laugh
something that i thought might be seven
years ago he tried to pick you up this
comedian
um yeah i told him trash tuesday which
is like yeah he tried it and the story
was interesting he brought you to the
car and tried to get a blowy or
something that's not me oh that was one
of the other girls annie yeah and um
cause is this such an interesting way to
pick up a girl i think to be like yo you
want to come to my car and suck my [ __ ]
anyway i should preface this by saying i
had a phone call with him all is squared
away and fine but he did promise we
promised that this would never be
brought up again but then he went on
flagrant two and talked about it so i
was like all right deal's off i'm gonna
talk about it on h deals off yeah so um
but i'll be delicate about it because i
do think that you know um
yeah i don't want to be an [ __ ] to
anybody yeah
right disaster um but are you friends
with him is that the problem are you
friends with with brendan
you're a queen synthesis
do you think he's a funny comedian
because a lot of people think he's great
okay
i think he's wonderful
i do i think yeah he's a good guy i
really do dynamic you know can i say
something about him all right i want to
say this all right um i want to say that
you try to get you try to [ __ ] your girl
all right so short is she short yeah
i like to say this about the man all
right you know how difficult it is to go
from one like
what
you don't have to like
do what right it's nice
you're you know what you're being a
power bottom right now oh you know what
because you're riding a stick not as an
insult yeah
i didn't say that as an insult i
literally just said it like because
you're writing his dick
only as a reference to what we talked
about in the beginning please guys
please just forgive me okay this one
time go ahead
okay so um you know it's very difficult
to go from one profession to another
right he was an mma fighter right
a really successful fighter very
successful um what was his professional
record
not the record that counts it's it's
what you do in the ring you know i mean
it's commitment
right right it takes balls to get in the
ring yeah it does take can you guys call
his profession his professional record
what does it matter i'm curious
so um
anyway so he you know and he goes into a
very difficult medium which is stand-up
comedy it's yeah it's clicky it's very
difficult it's very difficult
and he carves his way out and he does a
couple of specials he's a successful
podcaster and my hat's off to him
okay
yeah very okay good i mean nice thanks
all good vibes um we've we've talked and
um everything's under the rug and
everything's fine
and um
yeah
although i would like to clarify
this
has some nice things to say so i mean
you're you're in the middle of your
story well my problem with the whole
thing was
um when he had a problem with me he went
through bobby bobby was a filter and i
thought that was really um
not appropriate he wouldn't talk to you
no what is this you're doing a toothpick
nicotine toothpick i'm stressed out are
you serious
i didn't know they existed can i see
that i'm really interested in this
company's zip packs
because i chew yeah i chew nicotine gum
i'm sorry i just go faster
is there there's no jizz in here like
how clean are your hands and stuff
you think i touch every single one of
those you [ __ ] [ __ ] well sometimes
like i don't know a guy like bobby he
just like jizzes everything again
and it touches stuff yeah i don't jizz
on things man
yeah oh interesting they're nice right
that's a sponsor yeah good for you yeah
thanks oh watermelon flavor it's a
watermelon spearmint it's a combination
flavor you know what i mean um
peppermint i don't see it uh maybe
i was just getting some stuff i was
getting his profession
maybe where is it it's not in discord
but um leftovers discord from yesterday
oh about what you were starting to say
bro yeah go ahead
i i i want to protect bobby in all of
this ten and five oh he was ten and five
that's not bad we're [ __ ]
why are you so afraid because this is
the problem it all and it to his
defense
when this is good when shaab had a
problem with me never even saying his
name and by the way i neither confirm or
deny that that's to this day that that
story was about him well you guys said
his initials was bs and then annie said
it was bob saggett on the live show well
and then no one wants to get bs
no one of the things that really gave it
away yeah is that you guys said that
he's not very funny as a comedian and
then you guys all started laughing
objective
no but i know that's like a meme about
him i know you think he's funny yeah but
there's like a meme that everyone's like
he's the george carlo he's not funny
that doesn't mean
that they necessarily separate him so i
actually to this day i you never said
his name i never said it was assumed i
didn't think that it would escalate in
the way that it did i also didn't
realize that bobby would take the brunt
of the punishment um because nothing you
know he didn't do anything i didn't do
anything right here's the here's my
problem with just even this in general
okay and since it's really talking about
it [ __ ] it right but what i'm saying to
you is is that i have nothing to do with
any of it i don't even know what the
[ __ ] of the thing is about really you
don't like being put in the middle of it
not not was i not put in the middle of
it i was being um
screamed at
and bullied it was like
get your [ __ ] in line phone yeah
it was worse than that it was way worse
than that and my point is is that sorry
that's this now my fear is
the the results of whatever this is now
going to be there's no results because
there is there is a result
i can call shaab right now and we could
be like all is squared away and
everything is fine because we've already
talked about it the promise was that he
would never talk about it again and the
next day he went on flagrant too and
then talked about it even though it was
in a complimentary way yeah in a
complementary way i i don't feel like
we've said anything bad about him either
the point is did was there um
was there a text
alluding to possibly suing people yes
there was did it did it freak me out and
did it make me think oh [ __ ] like such a
small thing to sue over but was there a
lot of misunderstanding from his team
and us yeah and but we talked it through
but the truth is the truth
and you know it's all squared away
so
you guys are just going to get this
clear so you guys were talking about
there was this comedian that people
assumed was him yeah that was trying to
pick up all you girls kind of a sleaze
whatever right
so he calls you
and says bobby
your get your woman in line i mean what
kind of [ __ ] animal does that that's
[ __ ] up why didn't you call you he has
your number right i would assume it was
a different context yeah it's your
[ __ ] podcast who the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] it was not
just him
there was a whole barrage it was it was
don't say the name i'm not gonna but it
was a phone call with other podcasters
and it was that's some [ __ ] they
flogged you bro enough logged me they
threatened my career they called me
a coward
a [ __ ] you've always been a politician
and and um
they said they would expose me they said
that all these things and i was in
oklahoma shooting a show
and i was at dinner and i was by myself
and i was getting it was very traumatic
for me and
it was based on
whatever they did on the live now
imagine now what's going to happen with
now this it's good you said that i think
it's good that you're saying that
because you [ __ ] them
you shouldn't stand up for yourself yeah
but i just see these guys
every time every all the time but to
beat
buddy very
unacceptable
when that happened he called me like
shell shocked and crying at which point
i said give me his number
[Laughter]
poor bobby hey bobby
you're the best man the the man that has
feelings like what the [ __ ] are we
talking about he's like being spoken you
think she wants somebody say that again
back say that again for the people
we love men that can cry
[Applause]
bottom
so to be clear
the height of the chaos was when that
happened at which point i said i'm so
sorry dude yeah that's so [ __ ] up well
to both of you also not having like the
balls to talk to you he has the balls to
go and fight people but like why does he
gotta go do you even know what's going
on when you go
man you're like what are you guys
talking about he didn't know what it was
happening i don't know number one i
don't you were okay first of all
they were like we have evidence of
something right
so they said right they go we have 50
pages no they said 300 pages whatever of
of evidence brandon can't even read bro
how the [ __ ] that guy bringing 300 pages
of anything that guy's barely illiterate
are you kidding me this is where i think
that there's some
there's a disconnect between
food there's a disconnect between the
information he's being fed by his team i
don't think it's all him like he's just
like i have 300 pages of of proof that
um of an ip address that let's link
bobby's listen to this ethan thank you
bobby's computer i was like do you
realize called tech
saying that and basically that we've had
we've launched an attack on him for the
past five six years and i told brennan i
was like brandon with all due respect
like you're not an afterthought for us
like why would we as a company to
dedicate five six years to this
harassment on reddit when my sweet love
well because a lot of people hate
brandon there's like a whole like movie
so yeah he's trying to he blames that on
you guys
yes and so now we're at a point where
it's like well he says that he has proof
that
me
for the last five or six years that i've
been on reddit
you mean okay
[Laughter]
i've been spending my time
first of all number one i don't own a
computer i don't even know how to buy
one really you know man he really
doesn't
i don't know how to get on reddit i've
asked her how do you get on it what is
it you know right right i'm just not tac
tech savvy in that way you know it's
shameful to say but you know how
shameful you're an old you're what are
you like 50 60.
yeah so you are the best looking 50 year
old by the way thank you thank you you
are so youthful and your skin is so soft
so he was going you're doing this we can
trace the url back to your house and
you're the leader of this
reddit group i'm like bro first of all
if you look at from what i hear if you
look at reddit there are pages about me
as well
so i don't read it can i tell you
something yeah
as someone who's been in technology my
whole life yeah
people that don't know [ __ ] anything
about technology say that [ __ ] yeah but
i think it's impossible to get that
right he doesn't have it when anybody
says they have it i think proof against
you but ethan i think that i again i'll
defend him in this scenario by saying i
think his team is giving him a lot of
wrong information whatever that's
ultimately what him and i uh like um
were able to find common ground it's
like look i think i'm receiving wrong
information and i'm like i can i can
understand that i can forgive you he's
trying to scare you dan is a oh dan is
our tech wizard
he's walking with a bag of chips dan for
christ's sake
what's up
is it possible to get uh ip logs from
reddit that proves that bobby is posting
[ __ ] about brandon not without like
working at reddit i mean yeah or having
like a federal subpoena
um
yeah i don't need i didn't know what he
was saying i actually think we should i
could call him right now and get
clarification no no do not call him
wait we're okay him and i are okay now i
don't i don't i'm gonna say this no
after this no you will not be able to i
agree with that i promise you this and
this is this has opened no no no no i'm
not fine i'm fine all right i'm probably
fine totally fine but i'm just saying
that this has opened up a world home i'm
not a [ __ ] right i'm just saying the
thing is is that you guys don't do
stand-up right no right so i'm always
around them yeah right
i always have so i'm trying to play it
politically right i feel like i was
assaulted for something that i didn't do
at all i don't know even know what the
[ __ ] they're talking you truly have
nothing to do with it i have nothing to
do with and yet i was being you know i
mean um they put it all on hill right
because they're using you to try to
control what kalila is doing right right
so um you know i you know i went to
therapy and
about it you know i mean we talked about
it yesterday because it's like it was
just so traumatic and these were my
friends and i had no idea what the [ __ ]
they were talking about right and so
my whole thing was let's never talk
about it again
ever right and let's just brush it on
the rug so that i can go to comedy clubs
and look them in the eye and be
cordial right but now right this is a
whole nother [ __ ] thing
that i gotta deal with now yeah i see i
see your point yeah it just sucks
because
yeah it sounds like you they're trying
to bully you and it sucks that you're in
this position now yeah where you have to
it's like a boy it sounds like some
[ __ ] boys club where it's like she
like
let's be honest dude a lot of these
[ __ ] guys
have accusations against them
and it's a [ __ ] boys club and they're
all protecting each other and i'm not
saying that one did one
one did one you were talking about okay
fine
i'm not saying anyone did anything
specifically but it's like hey your
girl's out of line you know you got to
protect the boys and it's [ __ ] up it's
bowling [ __ ] dude
yeah and to and on flagrant to andrew
schultz's podcast he was like i
contacted kalila and i'm like no i asked
bobby for your new number and i really
wanted both he wanted to talk to you so
oh okay
all right so let's that's a two-way
street right let's be real all right he
won i don't like the narrative that he
was he came to me with with this because
it took
months or like two months before he even
wanted to come directly to the source
and i would have been
if he saw the first podcast on trash
tuesday and said hey i really didn't
like what you said it would have alluded
to me that's not good for me and then i
would have said i understand that i
didn't realize that you would be getting
extra harassment from all of this i
apologize i will not say it again it's
also not a cancelable offense to hit on
a woman it's not a big deal it was an
anecdote yeah and it could have been
resolved right then and there and i did
tell him that when i spoke to him a week
ago i said this was a very very simple
thing so from here on out moving forward
let's shake on it if you have a problem
with something i say come to me directly
and he said the same thing so we're good
we're good i promise you okay promise
you we're not no i promise you're not
and i promise you there's a wave coming
now and and that's it
unfortunately i i agree with bobby just
because i don't think they're gonna be
happy
that it's out there that they're [ __ ]
bullying bobby because those are these
are elements that i was never gonna
share
these are elements that i was gonna just
keep doing but is that okay like it's
not okay but you've got to live your
life yeah you got to live your life it's
okay with me because i'm doing first of
all number one um
would i say that they're friends of mine
anymore no they're out right i stopped
following them on social media okay
right and i did what i'm doing to
protect myself
you know what they did was not off what
a friend would do but he did apologize
to you bobby brendan did
yeah
yeah he did apologize but what i'm
saying is is that
the
the world didn't know what had happened
right right and so it's like you know
those are the elements that i was gonna
just kind of go you know let's brush
that to the side right
um i had my own way of processing it and
dealing with it politically because i'm
i do stand up every night and i start
i'm just around now
you know i have to now pick and choose
where i go up
right i do yeah i know i mean i have to
go and i go there that night because now
they're there right and it's just me
this has made it very difficult for me
you know and um
it sucks i'm sorry yeah i mean you know
it's out there and that's why i wish you
didn't do a live podcast
yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah
um i like to believe that this is i
better get a lot of teddy fresh [ __ ] i
mean bro i got i got i've got the ex i
don't i got the bulldozer
forever
forever you got it
but i don't like the idea of um because
of this now your life's gonna be worse i
don't know i've we've always lived under
like
not letting anyone bully us
and
i don't think you should tolerate that
behavior and if it means that you're
gonna
have to not perform on the same night as
them
maybe it's going to be better for you
though because you don't have to carry
this pretend and pretend that you're
like part of this group this men's group
that everything is good there the
problem nobody's rolling everybody
weddings that i'm going to
right how many times you go to weddings
you hate other people there you go [ __ ]
that guy yeah i stay on this side you
stay on that side they're the ones that
need to show up and be ashamed of
themselves
bottom line i understand that they need
to look at that i was just doing it
that i could do so that i could survive
you know i'm sorry i'm trying to see
maybe the positive side in it yeah yeah
there is no positive you know yeah um
but you know what
let's i'm going to tackle it head on you
know i mean i mean that's the only way
now to go forward you know but um i
think yeah i mean just to say what i
think it's good that people know what
happened because it's just not right
i know it's i think it's good for the
audience to know that these guys are
[ __ ] pack of rats dude
what do you mean they're a [ __ ]
they're a pack of rats bro these guys
are your friends and they gang up on you
bully you because because something that
your girlfriend said because kalila said
that nothing you do the guys are [ __ ]
clowns though bro they're they're meat
heads dude brandon schwab been punching
the head too many [ __ ] times
yeah
sure
yeah i mean
is there a question does he have what
junior sale has the ct i don't know yeah
i don't know you know what i mean but i
know it's not good to get punched in the
head good to be punched in the head yeah
but yeah go ahead
go ahead i i don't know if this is a
time the right time to like i think it's
a time to just put it all on the table
i don't think that's it
when i do talk to him i i feel like he
is a guy who's like hurting a lot and he
really loves his family and you know he
feels very like he feels horrible when
his kids are you know
being talked about a certain way when
his wife is being talked about a certain
way so i understand like his pain and
his feeling like he's on his he heals
like he has to defend who was talking
about his family i think that they're
the the reddit right
it's reddit
they'll [ __ ] ruin you if you go and
read what they're saying i mean
reddit is a [ __ ] vile place where
they say horrible things about everybody
yeah and that's what i told them it's
like shab whatever you're getting i get
everybody gets it yeah yeah everybody
gets it but i do think that he's
somebody who
i i don't know i have empathy for him i
mean that's horrible obviously to go
after people's family that's disgusting
yeah um
you know the comedy culture for me since
i moved there in the late 90s has always
been bullying
really yeah there's always been like a
yeah i mean
i never expected to hear that
no i really don't i'm surprised by that
yeah you laugh because it seems obvious
to you
yeah to me that it seems it's obvious um
you know it especially in certain clubs
it's always been a boys club i mean
there were boys i can't name names don't
literally walk up to
e cummings and chelsea handler and go
women aren't funny get out of here are
you [ __ ] kidding yeah and they would
say that to them right um
you know one time a comic threw ice
at natasha ledgero's face you know what
i mean
like get out of here you know i mean
like that type of mentality you know
i've always
used women as openers because i always
love them i've always been friends with
female comics i don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about but they've also
said stuff like that asians aren't funny
back in the day oh well that asians
don't do stand-up because they're not
funny they're not a funny people this
and that but all those things
are things for me to persevere
but because i'm a guy from trauma and
you know my parents my dad was so
violent growing up right i've always had
this thing of like i'll show you i'm
gonna get through this i'm gonna
prove you wrong you know and i feel like
i have done that you know i mean that
asians are funny we are we're funnier
than you are you know what i mean i'm i
can just get i can get as many laughs as
any other comic when i went and saw you
yeah i saw a few you crushed harder than
anyone people were electric for you yeah
so i so i know that ability but you know
because of the the the culture at the
time right of of bullying right i was
able i just felt like that was just a
part of the the nature of the sport wow
and um
you know i endured it you know
and because of what happened a couple
weeks ago whatever when i was bullied by
these guys right
it to me it's like the same mentality
it's like you know i'm just gonna you
know process it
deal with it in my own way and to find a
perspective
and
and my obviously my relationship with
certain people now have completely
changed it'll never go back the same
because at the end of the day like i
literally i know what i've done and what
i haven't done in my life all right
i do right you know right
you know when people accuse me a certain
thing there are some things like yeah i
did that you know i mean and there's a
couple of things that i've done
that one day i would like to talk about
on on podcasts that are like that i've
done to specific comics that are like
not cool you know what i mean um and i
know that i did those things and i feel
guilty and shame over it right but the
things that they were saying last week i
did that they came they came from such
left field right that like i was the
mastermind you know i mean behind this
reddit group that was after you know i
mean brendan schwab why would i do that
i i legitimate and this is honestly if
you saw bobby type on a laptop he he's
typewriter fingers he does this yeah i
do that right after you get two fingers
yeah but but that should tell you
something about their mentality that
they they have this they had this theory
working theory about you even before
this happened that you're somehow trying
to destroy
him yeah
i also would uplift
him and his crew and the people around
him there i say you've probably been one
of the most supportive people like when
he did first start doing stuff
i have i i he said that i remember i saw
a clip he said that bobby was really so
that you were really and i'm still
supportive of him you know i mean i i
think that he's funny i really
legitimately do the only one
you mean i mean there have been people
like there's a lot of comics that go you
know actors that do stand up later in
life right we don't support it i support
it you know i mean yeah i think that
jeremy piven is funny you know when
steve oh started doing stand-up me and
ian edwards went to his house and we
looked at his special and we gave him
notes and this and that right i mean i'm
that type of a guy right but it's like
um that's why when they
did that it was like whoa i'm an ally
what the [ __ ] are you doing right right
and um you know
that was based on something i didn't do
now because of this i'm just curious to
see what happens you know that's all
yeah yeah no i i feel you
i better get every color of teddy fresh
beanies every day i mean everything
everybody me too okay yeah you guys no
not you not you not you i want to buy
are you guys are you guys gonna are you
guys gonna argue after the podcast are
you angry that this got here i am no i i
think the
i've told bobby it's like i will work
out whatever i need to work out for
myself and set my own boundaries for
myself if that
that's the way it should be but
unfortunately these guys but um i do
feel bad for him because i think he gets
like i said the brunt of it all
um
but i'll probably call shop after this
and say hey this is what was said and
like
you know
i'm gonna stick to the promise of going
directly to him if i have but it's true
what's so wrong about saying oh he hit
on me it's like okay yeah
it wasn't it doesn't seem that bad i
mean well no well
not worse than you know other things
have been said about other comedians
okay
well you know it's like
that's a very interesting point ethan
you know it's like
what am i running away from it's like
you know we all have to look at
our behaviors and what we did and we
didn't do right and
own up to them you know um
[Music]
like i said before it's like you know
i think it was socrates or plato that's
a life not self-examined is a life not
worth living you know i mean i think
throughout you know the modern
day we've always been in
introspective and to look at your
character defects and your behaviors and
own up to these things you know what i
mean and i think that's the healthiest
thing to do but unfortunately we don't
live in a healthy
you know podcasting and stand up there's
just so much at stake i mean we you also
have fans against other fans i mean
there are fans that will only strictly
listen to whatever they they're doing
and vice versa tiger belly fans and you
know
i think our fans bleed over which is
cool i think we're very like-minded you
know i mean but you know um
once there's so much at stake and um
you have
the internet involved you know it gets
um
really muddled and
toxic yeah you know and i don't
like the toxicity
of it all you know i mean
all i'm trying to do is
make people laugh
you know all i'm trying to do is perform
and i like acting too so i act and i do
all these things because these are
things that i enjoy and i think people
enjoy me
for the most part
oh yeah watching me i mean so
um you know when all this now when all
these other elements are involved it
really makes me sad yeah and it makes me
uncomfortable and it
it's just unfucking unfortunate you know
i mean because i just don't understand
why we all can't just you know grow
together right you know i mean wouldn't
it be so much classier if he was like
you know i was i was a sleaze and i did
that and that was gross and people would
respect him right for that yeah
yeah
what's this meme here i don't maybe you
guys will get this alter ego in the bob
cave
i don't know what that means does this
make sense to you guys
no oh this isn't a meme this appears to
be we've obtained some of the evidence
okay oh this is you masterminding the
brendan schwab
what do you have to say about that yeah
so you pretend not to use it you're
pretending you don't know it but you
don't really have a wait wait how did
you come up with that right i just found
it
this is security footage
before the show yeah
he really thinks he found it on the
internet on google yeah see
you have an underground layer with
[ __ ] 20 monitors
yeah mass posting brendan schwab yeah
i mean it's like
i spend 12 hours a day playing stardew
valley you still play that i just
started playing because of the 1.5 i
have to do all the stuff on oh [ __ ]
that's crazy and it's so hard because
it's like there's this one thing where
you have to just
switch topics you know something i want
to talk about right is that there's a
when it rains there's a mermaid on the
beach and then you put these music
blocks on right but you have to click
them in a certain way it took me [ __ ]
two days to [ __ ] do that so what do
you do with the with the mermaid once
you get her once
you have to click the the music boxes in
a certain way where it plays her music
and she gives you five five walnuts
that's it walnuts
are walnuts good
in on the ginger island walnuts is like
the highest currency walnut is
everything yeah yeah yeah because i
could go to ralph's and buy some more
i'd probably
um but it's very and then q has a little
other challenges that i can't wait to do
later um
yeah last time you're on the show we
talked about stardew valley quite a bit
yeah he has a new game coming out called
the um the haunted chocolatier
the guy who made stardew yeah yeah and
i'm very excited about that i guess you
get just to change the subject for a
second um
you know what i mean
i'm so sorry to interrupt we got to go
to break
that's a sound bar a call back okay
you remember that yeah yeah
i continued with the chocolate
that was that was just a sound exactly
yeah but there's a little trailer um
that's on and um i don't know what the
gist but it's got the same kind of
pixelated thing and i think you um grind
for to you have a chocolate shop and you
make different chocolates you're excited
for the chocolate yeah because this guy
whatever he makes you're in
yeah there's like bethesda's coming up
with um
starfield which is an rpg in space
that's going to be
yeah that's gonna be much like skyrim
and a fallout and that comes out in
november so i'm very excited about that
as well you heard about that game star
field yeah it's bethesda's new game the
people waiting for he's just spending 15
years on you don't know about this wait
what star field yeah yeah that sounds
great some kind of [ __ ] loser i have
not even heard about this game did you
did you play um
did you play fallout and yeah i played
all that fallout skyrim i'm in big time
yeah yeah i'm in big time too oh that's
fun yeah it'll be fun but the trailer
looks really exciting you know there's
the bobcat pop cave again
we'll take care of that we'll get rid of
that i like it that's evidence
watch brandon schwab's going to send
that to you like bro i got the proof
right here
but yeah um back to the uncomfortable
part of it all um
i i literally still don't really have
hard feelings you know i think that
there's something wrong with them
mentally maybe you know what i mean i
mean there's some impact there's some
empathy that i have you know
to
his crew you know
but um yeah what's up well are you
touching my arm in that way i don't know
i'm trying to i'm trying to deliberate
whether or not i want to add this piece
of information or not well you might as
well be yeah
well one of
[ __ ] as it is so might as well i
really wish like my wish was for him to
be open about the situation as well so
there would be sort of this like okay
interesting growth but
um
one of the threats was to expose
something about me
about um
and
it was very specific thing about it
we might as well talk about about a time
about something that i had been doing
while bobby and i were broken up okay so
we
we had an open thing just take it all
from them okay so we had an open thing
right so that they can't use the
signature
yeah just put it on right so we had this
open thing and uh you guys had an open
relationship yeah i would lila saw
somebody in hawaii
lovely person lovely guy i like i know
the guy i like bobby hand selected him
mm-hmm literally yeah okay guys amazing
right so
we could trust so you arranged something
for her i didn't arrange it right you
you had this is gonna be okay and i said
go ahead and do it okay interesting and
this is something that you know this is
what my therapist knew about we talked
about it in couples counseling this and
that so this is something so it happened
right and it got leaked into the
internet right and now there's these
conspiracy series that she cheated on me
and whatnot right this is another
[ __ ] this is the most uncomfortable
podcast this is another thing that i was
gonna not talk about and now we're
talking about but why not nothing
happened if you're both comfortable
there's nothing to be ashamed about but
there's nothing to be ashamed about why
should people tired of like you know and
i hear it every day on online so just
from the show
that's we just did it but that was we
just [ __ ] did it man
i'm supporting you yeah that was one of
the things that was like if you know if
you don't get in line i'm gonna i have
nasty things to say about you too and i
was like sam also
you guys didn't do anything wrong like
the insinuations like i know about this
and i'm gonna [ __ ] blackmail you but
i do have to say that i after it went on
for a while i didn't feel comfortable
about it okay and i've now looked at her
maybe four months ago and i said i don't
want to do this anymore and let's go
stay monogamous again
oh this was happening up until recently
up until very reasonable okay
um
you know it's here's the here's
all right here we go
bobby let me just say what i have to
[ __ ] say
i will look in the [ __ ] mirror and uh
you know
as a podcaster there are a lot of things
that i have revealed
you know i mean because i've done
thousands of hours of talking as as of
you guys right but there are things that
i keep
still close to my heart that i'll never
reveal even this thing i'm willing to
talk about it but there are certain
things in my life that i'm really not
willing to talk about because it's no
one's business sure right and you know
for me to survive
be by being a podcaster there are things
that i have to keep sacred to myself
yeah okay
and so um
that's why i don't talk about certain
things you know what i mean because it's
like it's none of no one's business this
was one of them right and this was one
of them and now
it's everyone's business because i'll
tell you why though the reason why i'm
willing to talk about it is because of
the fact that it's you know
there's too much
rumor
and stuff on the internet you know i
mean um
about it people are coming up with their
own conclusions and this and it's like i
just might as well clear it up and
that's the reality of the situation
another thing is another thing that i'm
willing to admit is
is i haven't had seen pornography in
four months okay
that's great
sorry
good for you your dog just said why he
goes
yeah
but um and the reason why is because for
many many years um
you know i mean i wasn't intimate with
kalila because of my chronic
pornography addiction right which led to
us having this open thing because i
didn't know what to do right so it's
like you know um
it's it's another thing that's personal
and that i wasn't really willing to talk
about because no one's [ __ ] business
you know um my relationship with kalila
is sacred
um you know we share a beautiful life
together
we have seven animals a house we have
kind of a daughter juliana is kind of
our daughter and we're proud of her
growth and whatnot and um you know you
you want to be able to keep stuff to
yourself um i have dreams and
aspirations outside of show business as
well
um and um
that's the fact you know i mean i'm not
ashamed of anything i'm not embarrassed
about anything about my life um that's
that you know um that's the reality you
know
um
and these are things that people
have used to blackmail me right to
expose you yeah i i it's like we're you
know i mean so i'm willing to take that
head on
um
yeah
that's uh thank you for sharing that i'm
sorry that you had to even talk about it
this whole thing has been uncomfortable
but it's good you take the power yeah
it's good you take the power from them
yeah it's you know but maybe this is the
healthiest way to do it i don't know you
know in retrospect you know when i
scream at her in the car
we'll see
we'll see
we'll see what happens
my personal philosophy i know it's just
me but i i always like to
get stuff like this out in the open and
[ __ ] like this happens to me all the
time for some reason where getting the
beef i'm being sued four [ __ ] times
by one billionaire he's sued me four
times i've won two already frank
kavanaugh by the way google his name
brian cavanaugh orion kavanaugh okay
yeah ryan kevin
four times he's a piece of [ __ ] wow okay
copyright infringement defamation
tortious interference and he tried to
get our website taken down does ryan
cavanaugh look like harvey weinstein
which is the top resort by result result
by the way if you type frank cavanaugh
yeah yeah even before wikipedia does he
look like um
you want to see it i'd love to see the
company i'll be the judge but the point
i was trying to make is that in my life
the one thing i've done is never shy
from conflict and always take things
head on especially when i feel like i'm
being bullied and it has served me very
well in life
it's not for everyone though yeah like i
went i went on uh tom and christina's
podcast and he goes and people always
ask me how how are you so comfortable
with everyone hating you or how are you
so comfortable just like getting all
these conflicts and i don't know but
here's the thing before you go into that
um ethan is is that you know i'm not
comfortable with it yeah yeah right you
know i uh not for everybody yeah i'm not
a um i don't like confrontation yeah you
know i mean i like to i'm more namaste
like steven seagal you know what i mean
i you know even stephen
i know but he says
says it all the time so it's like you
hear how he says vladimir putin's name
hit it
he put so much respect
with so much respect so um for me i i've
i don't like it
i understand yeah
anyway
but you know sometimes it's well let's
see how it turns out for you this time
are you okay
no
i'm not okay yeah yeah yeah
well you want to see something funny
yeah that's why i want to say you type
ryan cavanaugh second result today
does ryan kavanagh look like harvey
weinstein so here
this is ryan cavanaugh yeah he was the
uh
founder of relativity media which was a
big production company
yeah he utterly bankrupted it oh yeah oh
brutal one of the worst
most cataclysmic bankruptcies in what is
bad
so this is the poll we took it says
you know
this many people think he looks like
harvey weinstein and this many don't so
clearly the public is confused which is
why we made this website now here's
harvey weinstein here's
they have similar yeah i mean look at
this if you don't i mean look at this
yeah i like but i have a theory i think
that god when god created man you know i
mean for a white man and every every
actually ethnicity and stuff right and
race and he he um made 20 prototypes
right interesting so he's definitely
you know because you know sometimes
you'll go to like
you know you'll go to asia and you'll
see a guy that looks like oh that asian
that looks like denzel washington like
there's like a prototype right you know
what i mean you know and i think they
are definitely the same there you go you
see so you're backing my theory but yeah
yeah and if you scroll down you can see
what's really interesting is here you
can see ryan cavanaugh kissing harvey
weinstein yeah he loved him a lot yeah
you know what you made me uncomfortable
today babe so i'm gonna i'm gonna say
something that's gonna make you
uncomfortable go ahead so on the car
right over here i told her that i was
trying to watch the um john wayne casey
oh i saw that i watched it right and she
goes from the netflix thing that's nice
he looks like ethan that's what you said
you're john wayne casey hey
that's crazy that's not how i said it
well here's here he is it's just the
cover and we both said who did he look
like and on our way here
that reminds you of me
and i didn't say that you [ __ ] said
it well listen
i didn't like i didn't like kill anyone
or uh
so if i look like the guy and that's not
even how it was said it was literally
like who does he look like who does he
i'm on our way here bobby's like does he
look like ethan maybe
you are twisted whatever you're [ __ ]
doing right now dude is so wrong
but i'm not mad i know you're not mad
but i'm just saying reach inside your
heart right reach the side of your heart
and really look at yourself in the
mirror because i didn't even equate it
because i [ __ ] saw the thing last
night and no time did i go there's ethan
not one time you sent it in the car
that's on you
and that's something that you have to
[ __ ] live with
okay i don't see the resemblance but i'm
not angry i mean i'm generic kind of
chubby yeah yeah i think it's just the
hair it's the hair yeah his hair is
straight no i mean in the picture in the
the cover of the netflix not here you
don't look like him here at all yeah
yeah did you like that documentary he's
a sicko eh
you know what thing is is that you know
who i'm more mad about is his mom
his mom lived in that house and there's
like 60 bodies just in the in the wall
yeah right under the bed how do you
[ __ ] not know
because all these serial killers the one
thing they all have in common is they
had a parent their parents are [ __ ]
them up yeah no i i i understand that
what i'm saying that his mom was some
old weirdo
of course there was there has to be he
was pretty good at hiding the bodies
though he dressed up as a clown isn't
that [ __ ] up oh my god yeah yeah yeah
so you don't watch this yet you don't
think that it's too creepy you don't
think that two really balanced good
people can have a psychopath no no i
don't think so i don't i don't think
there's an argument we had the other day
i don't even think like a serial killer
yeah just like completely just born with
because she doesn't have a kid with me
because she's like what that's not also
that's also not the truth no but that's
not the truth i do want a kid i know but
i'm just saying but you've you've thrown
this idea around that what if we have a
serial killer or a masculine well it's
not a normal conversation to have in
that way i don't think right i think i
think it's about how you raise the kid
yeah we have uh i haven't heard you guys
we did a poll
seventy-seven percent saying it looked
like
casey so thank you guys yeah yeah yeah
thank you so much for bringing that up
from our reddit someone said the same
exact thing that you look like the cover
of that documentary great thank you guys
thanks for bringing that up you're
welcome yeah thank you so much you can
do polls really quickly so we can do any
polls you want
i want to do a poll it's live yeah
whatever you want
so a lot of times i'll walk around and
people go hang
you may know that to drive by and just
yell hangover right this thing like that
i'm dr ken chung which is fine that's
right
you guys look nothing i know i said
nothing alive but i'm fine nothing in
life talented guy but what i'm just
saying that when i look in the mirror i
just kind of go it's not even the same
pronoun i don't know
you know who you look look more like
probably benedict wong
more of a prototype yeah i think ben and
i'm proud of that let me pull that out
yeah yeah
benedict wong yeah i think that's more
your prototype not ken jong yeah yeah
wait this guy yeah benedict and i have
from doctor strange dr frank oh this
guy's badass i love this guy yeah i have
the same prototype i believe so are you
guys both filipino no no i'm korean and
he's benedict is chinese oh interesting
and he came to my birthday party he did
well no i did
well not necessarily no so what happened
was
what does that mean
no so
what happened was i had a birthday party
in korea town right
and then i was doing a show for
dumbfounded and aquafina was there and
aquafina brought benedict but then
benedict and i
hung out and we talked we took a photo
it was like he was like a very like
cosmic almost like you guys connected
not even in a deep way like it was like
did you guys exchange numbers yeah oh so
you guys are better yeah we're buddies
yeah um i just think he's such a great
actor is he bit he's tall he's a bigger
guy yeah because he's like a kung fu guy
yeah he's a um
chunk
he's a chunky hunky yeah he's chunky
a [ __ ] chunky i didn't say that yeah
yeah you wanted so did you no
didn't even think about it uh so what
poll did you want to do
do i look like dr ken
oh i i put one up that asked if you
looked like him or benedict or neither
okay good good thank you so much for
that yeah so dr can
dr uh ken uh is losing by a lot he's at
fourteen percent right now uh benedict
huang a forty percent say that there's a
resemblance there but the main the
plurality is actually neither 47 can you
pull up the pole please so we can see
the results yeah there
second
just so you know we're not making it up
you know it's a real
thing
there we go a lot of technical ins and
outs you know i like it
um
so we have does bobby look like ken
neither benedict or neither
awesome they're you're your own man yeah
yeah awesome thank you what about sandra
oh didn't you don't you get that
yeah don't put sandra oh in there
because i don't want to i don't even
want to know okay wait i swear you have
been
is that not true somebody did yell out
you know i mean grey's anatomy sandra oh
oh i see the resemblance here cake
because of my long hair
yeah no that's that's dead on that's a
spit again
that one they got you on that one i
think my breasts are way bigger
yeah yeah
she's a sweet lady i love a very sweet
lady
the first acting job i ever got was a
show called arliss on hbo had two lines
and she was the star of it this is back
in the late 90s
and
because i'm korean she's korean
she was just super like kind to me like
thanks for doing the show and you know
people talk for a very long time what a
sweet lady and every i've run into her
maybe three times in my life and every
time she remembers and she's that's he's
a knife that's beautiful you run into a
hero of yours that
uh
i had bill burr on the show who
eviscerated me right he [ __ ] made but
he put me on antidepressants
did he eviscerate you yeah yeah yeah it
was bad
what what did he what did he say no i'm
kidding it's fine he came back we had a
great show yeah the first show i think i
was just nervous i wasn't on any
medicine i was very anxious
so sometimes i get in this anxious mood
and my brain gets foggy and i'm not
super sharp perspective of like
fanning out like we were listening to
his podcast every day during that night
ah
yeah he turned on me a few times yeah
where i was like guy you remember in
philadelphia when
you turned on the crowd you know told
him he goes oh not you you're bringing
that i thought you were cool and now
you're bringing that up and i just i
don't know i just
it was just a mess it was i'm on
medication too what medications are you
on i'm on lexapro 20 milligrams
yeah
yeah
and i started wellbutrin because i
gained so much weight
and that's supposed to help me lose
weight but i had started having like
this crazy allergic reaction i don't
know if it was from wellbutrin or
something else so i stopped that i'm
hoping to get back on it when i wanted
to figure out what but yeah lex brown
i'm on a low dosage of uh
ritalin really yeah yeah okay this would
be really helping is that a new
development for you mm-hmm i've never
been on medication before oh really yeah
so the lexapro was like life-changing
for me yeah i think his life honestly
like because of this podcast
you're going to have to up the dose no
no i'm not going to touch it i honestly
i think that
if i wasn't on
the ritalin right
i have a very slow small dosage um
i would have reacted differently
so you have like the ritalin is for adh
adhd right and you got a little anxiety
as well really because literal because
for ritalin is upper but i guess if you
have adhd it makes it slows you down
that's very opposite that's so
interesting it really makes i could
sleep on it wow because i i took it once
and i was like wired for like a [ __ ]
week and i oh really it [ __ ] me up he
wasn't able to sleep one time for like
six days like he was really having a lot
of just like very almost like manic um
kind of this is when he relapsed
recently as well right and so um when he
started on ritalin all of a sudden he
can sleep the whole night wow wow that's
great i say medicine man there that [ __ ]
works it's really good i take like
support too and i love it yeah oh you do
yeah yeah yeah and i took it through the
whole pregnancy and everything
i was on everything under the sun
yeah so when i was younger i
um i was on zoloft i was on cyprexa like
anti-psychotics even to like just bring
me down completely because i was like
very suicidal wow and i had such a bad
experience with ssris and just general
meds in general that that it
i stopped taking it for like the last 10
years of my life but now i'm realizing
that it was never calibrated correctly
for me or in with consideration of like
my teenage kind of thing especially if
you're suicidal it needs like really
really
strict
yeah oversight but now i really am like
reconsidering you know getting back on
like an ssri you know if you have a
psychiatrist you like and you're like my
psychiatrist i can text i can call them
if i'm having any side and like i'm i
just think it's it's really powerful and
a great thing so why i had to see four
or one of my live stream four because i
and everyone said we think you know i
mean this would work
so eventually i was because because i
always thought that it was going to
affect
the way i performed you know what we
were that was my biggest fear yeah and
the lexapro liberated me yeah because i
was no longer anxious and in my head and
depressed and all these [ __ ] up moods
yeah it liberated me it made me
my work
way better it made it better yeah it
helped me the same way yeah even last
night i did a show
and you even said it was
yeah you were incredible yeah it was
much more
because what happens is you know before
i would be doing stand-up and if things
weren't going well right i would speed
up right and i would just i would think
so fast right that i couldn't even you
know i mean catch my thoughts so this
slows you down yeah yeah interesting
kind of like when i'm on stage now it's
like if something happens it's like for
instance
you know a lot of every time this
happens when i perform a woman will just
get up and leave
that [ __ ] with you it [ __ ] with me
it's always like is it like [ __ ] this
guy get up or it could be a bathroom
thing no no no no that's not true when i
was in the or wednesday this is what
happened
she goes i'll just demonstrate it right
she's sitting there
like this
she was pissed and then she stood in the
back room and she put her arms like this
and she did this you could see it all
right what was the joke you thought did
you joke about my purple vagina no no no
no it was about um
i think it was my asian homeless job oh
yeah was she asian no that's not that
interesting right and she stood there
back like this and i just went you know
normally if i wasn't on something it
would just be like oh god
you're [ __ ] your failure oh no really
get in your head and i wouldn't say it
or even say it on my face it would just
be like in my head like why yeah is she
getting up this and that but it when it
that happened it was just like ah i
don't care yeah you know and i just got
called you gonna stand up back there the
whole time you called her out oh yeah
yeah i'm standing there like this
and she came back oh [ __ ] she came back
and sat down you get any laughs from her
yeah she started you know oh the crowd
started laughing this and that and i was
just like seeing you you bet
relaxing
yeah um but
it just yeah it really does help
i'm happy for that yeah
that's good
it really helped me i can't i can't
overstate it i was a [ __ ] mess yeah
and uh it really you taught me a
technique i did yeah i think one of the
times here about like
i forgot how you worded it but it's
basically being bored
going in and just kind of going just be
boring
oh don't be boring yeah be boring don't
try so hard don't try so hard yeah just
be boring yeah be boring
and it really does work that's my
technique for interviewing people yeah
yeah or whenever we would go somewhere
like if oh when i do interviews yeah we
were invited for example for hot ones
and we would get all nervous before oh
yeah yeah and like is that delicious
exactly
like that's good just be boring just
remember be boring you don't need
the reason why you get anxiety is
because online they have competitions on
which hot ones is the best yeah
you know i still have resentment because
when i did that show i feel like sean
evans [ __ ] me because
i thought i was doing good with the
spicy i wasn't really affected i'm good
with spicy food yeah and he wasn't
encouraging me
to like finish my bones he was like
don't have to finish it you know most
people don't finish you just take a
little bite and you're done yeah and
looking back and how it's evolved i wish
i would have gone more for the spicy and
i feel like sean sabotaged me
yeah i think that's on you yeah yeah
instinctually i'm like it's funnier if
i'm in pain it's [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] that up man that is a big
opportunity yeah maybe you should have
been boring
i was and that was the problem maybe i
shouldn't have been boring yeah i'm
kidding man you know are we [ __ ]
are we [ __ ] oh yes you're worried
about uh
yeah did you get yeah
why did something happen
or did you see it check your phone or
read about like i just
you know how i know you're nervous what
you have a little pool above yourself
i'm sweating yeah yeah yeah it's more
just check my armpits
is it hot no oh can we get the ac please
oh my god
yeah what's going through your mind
right now um i think it i finally felt
relief from um getting into like a
common place with job over in the pad
last week that now i feel like it's just
um
war zone again
it's it's going to be a disaster
yeah yeah but at least now you can talk
about it on your show be open with about
everything that's happening
can i argue against that sure real quick
yeah um just
i just want to know right
because this is entertainment
right what we're doing right now i mean
essentially
when i talk to you off screen right
is that what i'm getting here on screen
yeah i i i i my argument is that i'm not
i feel like that this personality that
we have here right
is although very close to who we are and
we are being authentically ourselves but
we are but there are cameras on we are
very aware that people are listening
right so that does right affect
everything right i don't think anyone
can be essentially themselves for me
that's a hundred percent true yeah as if
there's any lights or camera looking my
way like i'm so sensitive to um
just being with you that it forget it
like my natural normal self is out the
window i'm just gonna be always in my
head about how i'm being
because there's you know when i podcast
there's like eighty percent of the
stories that i tell
are lies
oh you just make them up
there's they they come from bases on
it's like stand up right you tell it you
can't just tell a story outright
because if you tell a story outright no
one's gonna laugh right you gotta find
switches and different things
exaggerations to elevate you know i mean
you know instinctually that's it right
so it's like you know i've over the 20
years of doing radio and and podcasting
obviously
all of it is exaggerated or
i take somebody else's story and i make
it my own vice versa you know different
things right so it's not really you know
the truth but you're operating with like
i agree with that okay that's what i
want to that's when i so i feel like we
can tell a story the way it is and it's
interesting and we don't
and i feel like
no we're back we're better no
yeah yeah that's not what i'm saying i'm
just saying like
i know what you're right
maybe that's what it is yeah you come
from the stand-up brain yeah i i i
operate i know what you mean like it's
in front of a live audience and that
yeah i want to
make it compelling yeah right
so for me i guess that's how i operate
right so when it comes to like
real things like what we talked about
with brandon and this and that i try to
essentially kind of you know avoid them
because they seem
um very real and there's like real life
consequences to
those that type of confrontation right
so that's why
i generally avoid it it's not me being a
coward
or a [ __ ] because obviously i'm taking
it head-on now right but essentially
that's why i don't
talk about that those kind of things on
our podcast even
you know i mean our break and her seeing
that guy from hawaii we haven't talked
about it on tiger belly because
i just find it to be no one's real
business sure that's okay yeah that's
different but i'm saying
i feel like if things are
if things are becoming a problem or
whatever
you know sometimes it's good to share
certain things with the audience but you
have your way of doing things you know
yeah and it works for you but yeah
but let me ask you this though can i ask
you a question anything you want and i
want to learn from you because you
taught me the boring thing okay good so
what i'm saying
how do you deal with
harassment and online things of that
nature well the way i deal with that is
that i don't i [ __ ] fight back
always if people try to [ __ ] me over
like this ryan cat oh you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you guys did that
it's very similar you guys did that
you're right babe and guess what you're
going under my [ __ ] uh bit you're
going under the
under the house after i have sex with
your boss
yeah yeah i'm turning into john john
gacy for you yeah how um
how much the people i really like to
speculate or really put their energy
into like
your relationship with ethan like and
how do you deal with that like i always
feel like there's just
that's the hardest part for me to deal
with like i've been with him for 10
years but there's always like
you know she's
there's always that like a question of
what my intentions are in the
relationship and stuff like that like
how do you deal with that
i guess where we sometimes get it most
recently is more like our dynamic with
the crew let's say because we'll all
have a very open conversation about
something and it can come off as like oh
they're mistreating their employees or
yeah um i don't know they say that to me
because i'm a bully
okay george kimmel to george kimmel you
know or somebody goes but it's [ __ ] so
lately dynamic but lately i've had to
think like how do i deal with this
because
i personally like the then the
conversations and i think it's good for
the show yeah and i don't think anything
was wrong about it so you know what's
the best time to learn sorry i just cut
i just try to [ __ ] cut you off so
hard it's fine and i don't care if it
cuts me off so that's the kind of thing
that people like to get upset about
[Laughter]
i'm glad i caught myself um it's just i
guess i am learning to
push it away when it comes to things
that i know for a fact how i feel about
it
if i know for a fact that i love these
guys here and we have a good
relationship where i know that we're
good employers and we treat them well
then you know if there's noise about it
i'm just gonna ignore it because i know
what the truth
is of what's happening you know
that's like something that was the most
recent that i can think of that i had to
like
it was messing with my head like i
didn't know what was happening for a
moment yeah
two things that worked for me the
comments and people's opinion you still
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up so bad
one i stopped reading comments for the
most part
stopped engaging
and two
lex pro and therapy
and i'm like if we have like a weird
conversation that i know is going to be
heated on the interwebs i'm like okay
i'm going to avoid reddit for a week and
i really don't go there for a week yeah
but if it's if it's fine and like we're
having good times and no drama i'll
probably check reddit and
look at stuff and look at comments but i
just selectively
will tell myself this is not a good time
to look that's a good tip we should just
stay away from social media because you
should you just shouldn't yeah you
shouldn't yeah don't look
i mean because yuri
i tell you i i you think that i i know
that longer read the comments you don't
no i cannot that's because it's like it
shifts my move yes right it does you
know like even like people will go
hell i hate to tell you this dude but
you're a terrible actor
just in a random car in a random comment
right and i'll read that and i'll go
into myself right and i'll go they're
right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it'll rule my name so it's like
instead of doing that i just don't read
it yeah yeah i stopped you know for a
while that was blocking people because
they were saying some crazy [ __ ] you
know i mean and i and i
instead of doing that now i just why
read it
the thing about internet comma susie you
don't know who's writing it could be a
[ __ ] 13 year old kid yeah that if he
came up to you on the street and said
some [ __ ] you'd be like [ __ ] you kid
like you you your opinion literally your
brain is not formed yet yeah and the
word you don't know who they and the
worst thing here's the [ __ ] thing
that sorry that pisses me off the
[ __ ] mouse yeah here we [ __ ] go
dude all right
is when they go kalila's too hot for you
oh that's that then no one says that
anymore i know but they used to [ __ ]
do it i'm hot too man isn't that a
compliment to you yeah i sex too man
does that upset you
that people don't find you as attractive
as kalylah i am
but he really is i am i it's like people
go
people go oh i can't believe bobby
landed the kaleila it's not fair i go
really [ __ ] have you done what i've
done right but that's a very american
way of seeing beauty because i grew up
in asia i grew up around koreans i
grabbed
it's just you're hot to me when i first
look at you and she likes your dick she
said she was when she saw your dick she
was like nice yeah if you have one color
on your dick that's not good yeah you
need three at least i know a guy that
yeah i know others is great
you need five colors right right i just
say i know a guy with five colors on his
dick right
what are the two he has her he has
herpes
yeah he has hpv and herpes do they say
that about you that like she's too hot
because she's beautiful
oh well
i feel like we used to get that yeah i
think we no longer get that either yeah
it doesn't bother me because i know i'm
a monster i get mixed feelings oh not
mixed
the whole the thing is i have no
insecurities about my physical
appearance i used to be handsome
long time ago
long long time ago
but like i know i'm a monster
i never really put much stock in my
physical appearance
but we're good i'm i'm i would not
choose anybody else
over anything but i know like i'm secure
very good
and so
you know we have like you said
a sacred relationship
we have two kids we've been together for
like 15 years i'm just i'm not insecure
about that
and you know i'm just [ __ ] i'm a
hideous beast and i don't like it but
like i know that you know i'm a i'm a
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] sloth and
battle
yeah i do do you use it absolutely not
yeah you got to use it
right you know what you do what i do
right here's what i do yeah do you watch
things like do you watch things yeah
what's your favorite tv show right now
right now we're watching uh raised by
wolves raised by i heard that was good
it's very good yeah yeah i'm gonna watch
start watching yeah yeah very good so
what you do is you take an episode of
raised by wolves right get on the
peloton you do this not the scenic one
but just the free rides yeah the screen
is blank right i don't like the pressure
i don't need something like buff you
know what i mean like straight going you
know come on buddy lift the [ __ ]
thing you're right i don't need that no
i don't like i want to watch my show i
shouldn't say gay black dude
it could be anybody yeah trying to think
of a gay black site because i know all
the instructors on peloton yeah yeah um
no well i've never seen the instructor
so i just made that up i apologize it's
fine that's the exaggeration part i was
telling you yeah right i just make
things up my point is is that this so i
watch like hoarders i love orders right
i watch that show
yeah
over and over again exactly yeah yeah i
love it you watch the same wow
i watch every season
and i'll just i'll go from season one i
do that with star trek next generation i
love next gen what's your favorite app
oh the inner light which one is that is
that the one where he like lives a whole
lifetime yes that is a beautiful one
he's in the
five
the 11th episode with the flu
second to last yes the flute season 5
episode 25 what
season 5 episode 25 you got you got the
right season though
beautiful uh episode what episode what
part of that show i like right is what
what part do you remember from that
episode
um the ending with the like he's back
which kind of shocked me that episode is
he's like [ __ ] i just lived the whole
[ __ ] life in our whole family and
he's like well let's get on with it
yeah yeah yeah right yeah some ptsd and
whatnot yeah yeah yeah because he had
kids in it too he had a kid yeah yeah he
had a whole [ __ ] family he like lived
the whole life with this beautiful
family i remember and then at the end
she was like
let's go
but that's what happens with dreams i
think like i sometimes have these really
vivid vivid dreams and it takes me for
i'm still reeling for four days like if
and the same thing if i have like kids
in in my dream or if i'm in love with
let's say for if i'm in a relationship
with say harry styles like i'm still i
wake i feel all those feelings in the
dream so when i wake up i i can't just
shake it off yeah he did sometimes yeah
he did i think
how beautiful was that i cry every time
when so he pulls up the flute he doesn't
go
he doesn't do that right all right right
yeah
right yeah and there is a pan
so the shot is the last shot is you see
the window of his uh you know his i
don't call it his cabin or his office
yeah whatever right and they pan out and
you see his back i think and he's just
playing the thing and i'm just
i started crying it's a beautiful it's
one of the best shows yeah i i honest
and then there's another episode called
lower decks i think it was one of the
last uh seasons right and it focused on
not the main people but the people that
are the lower the lower deck yeah
i like that as well you know what i mean
the one it's kind of uh maybe
a little bit obvious but the one where
they were trying to take data back to
earth and reassign them because they
they didn't treat him like a sentient
being and they had the whole tribunal
about if data was a oh
yeah yeah yeah i like so good yeah
measurement man measure of man thank you
oh man yeah i mean um there were certain
ones though when they go back in time i
don't i'm not a big fan of that they're
not all hits they're not like the
sherlock holmes one yeah not that good
yeah the true lockhart one or that yeah
moriarty what here's the nightmare the
moriarty in those episodes right i think
there was a couple of episodes with that
guy in it right yeah and they
he knows that he's an assimilation yeah
but he's trapped in this thing
and he tries to get out yeah
it's just a nightmare for that character
right yeah yeah anyway that makes sense
though
so the peloton
the [ __ ] peloton yeah right you're
not going to do an argument no no are
you what do you think i didn't think
about this trying to watch a show and do
the belt on i go downstairs with a belt
on it and i say [ __ ] that i'ma sit on
the couch and watch the show
we even had a setup for him to play
video games and do it and he did it oh
really he did it for a little bit yeah
yeah yeah i gotta i have to prep myself
mentally you know the the lex
what
no have you ever done a podcast it was
towards my [ __ ] mouth bro yeah you're
right
yeah that was unprofessional dude i
don't want to yell at your [ __ ] guy
tell him all right dude you're right
sorry
it was just a little too slanted okay is
it good now yes all right
thank you thank you you're welcome thank
you the alexa pro can make you gain a
lot of weight when i told my new
psychiatrist how much weight i gained
he's like you gained a lot of weight
yeah you look different that's fine to
say i'm not upset not in a bad way i
just think you do i'm fatter that's what
you mean no you look
fatter yeah
because i haven't seen you in a while
and yeah a lot and so i started the lux
when i gained a [ __ ] lot of weight
yeah the thing with the little is i pee
a lot i hate it interesting yeah yeah
yeah i pee do you drink a lot more i
should
are you but how do you pee more without
consuming more liquid you know what i
mean there's something i just do i drink
a lot of coffee but then my um people
are saying especially her
because i pee a lot i don't drink water
i hate water you have to drink water
like water
i mean it's like it doesn't like water
it's like kind of a you gotta it's like
you have to drink it
yeah he absolutely hates water it's
gotta be flavored something that's soda
water
soda water is basically water what does
that work the same yes
so okay i could do that yeah soda water
works what about if you drink with ice
to me it makes the water taste better a
little exciting yeah yeah we didn't have
an ice maker we still don't yeah we
don't we haven't had like we just we
don't have a nice a lot of things okay
we have one of those fridges that like
get to the ice
you know the people used to [ __ ] kill
for ice we have technology you could
shoot cubes in your [ __ ] living room
man okay what when
they were so back in the day pioneer
dudes they had the like that we can't
get no [ __ ]
[ __ ] dig ice out of the goddamn
frozen lake and drag big-ass cubes in
the village so they can [ __ ]
refrigerate their meat oh oh the meat
yeah yeah why can't you make jerky
well i like jerky yeah different process
like back in the viking days right they
used to take whale blubber and whales
and stuff yeah and they would make it
into jerky for the offseason
not good but they happened
to do it yeah yeah but yes soda water
works just the same i drink a lot of
soda water
you know in europe they they drink a lot
of places they don't drink still water
that's like peasant [ __ ] they bubble
they have like their own carbonators i'm
serious yeah and they carbonate their
water because they don't [ __ ] with
normal water yeah but you're not afraid
though i i'm not a doctor right and i'm
asking you this ela too is is that
he's going to get diabetes or he's going
to die younger i don't think it's
cardiovascular
i'm not happy about it i'm kind of rich
of you you're pre-diabetic you're so
hurt that's why i'm saying it i'm
worried about it first of all yes i'm
not happy it's unhealthy i've got to
take care of this issue that's why i
went to the psychiatrist i was like
we got to do something so the wellbutrin
i'm trying to get on and i'm doing
better with my food i hired this meal
service they bring me healthy foods i
was actually doing really good and i had
this [ __ ] insane allergic reaction to
something i had to stop everything but
in terms of foods what do you eat
well you go crazy
like when you guys go to dinner
do you look at him and go ah
i can't do that anymore because i don't
want to trigger i just no but silently
do you judge me sometimes
sometimes you went from like ordering
one thing for you to ordering like two
things you know yeah sometimes you know
what happened to like ordering one thing
you go to a restaurant no it's okay not
a restaurant like we do a lot of
delivery oh delivery
what's your favorite because i have i
can show you my doordash and my i'll
tell you what my favorite
yes your favorite but you're saying food
yeah yeah
what's the place that you order the most
because it says mexican food which one
oh i don't know i just i fulfilled it
through them i have so many oh
i love mexican food oh there's one i've
been actually [ __ ] with lately la
fuentes colo fuentes las flint las vegas
you know that place if it's the one i'm
thinking of yeah that place is hold on
let me it's [ __ ]
insane go there after yeah
i want to go there i want to yeah i used
to go there all the time when i lived
out there i think it
let me view the address because
i'm surprised they're bringing it from
receded that doesn't make sense
but maybe they have a couple maybe they
have a few locations it's in resida they
[ __ ] deliver that [ __ ] from a cedar
oh yeah no wonder it's cold when it
arrives
yeah it's
so good it is oh my god los fuentes dude
those [ __ ] are doing some [ __ ] in
that kitchen yeah i want it and the
salsa i want to eat it
austria is one of mine what is it
australia australia
and they're on they're on the ordering
app yeah yeah yeah okay really good
italian food
oh we must have been there yeah yeah
you're the [ __ ] with the top there's
one on melrose and there's now one on
sherman
yeah yeah very good but jersey mike's a
lot too
you know drinking like
i can't do that one it's a lot of too
much meat for her yeah i don't ever get
to order that yeah oh you don't like
meat no no you don't eat meat at all
i'll eat sometimes very little she's
mostly vegetarian yeah
you know we're very similar too because
of the you love animals as well how many
dogs you have now two dogs they're right
they're here yeah yeah
look at them they're so sweet
four dogs four dogs three cats oh three
cats did you have four dogs when i would
did your guys podcast last year no no it
wasn't you got more
one of our dogs can't do that
yeah we have a dog named julio
who cannot be around anyone new like if
you didn't know
shredder's like that yeah if strangers
come into the house he'll [ __ ] he'll
try to take a chunk up there oh really
yeah yeah but it's so small that it's
not actually like you know a problem
yeah yeah it's like a mosquito bite do
you have cats or no never have you don't
like them
i don't know we've had like uh we used
to live with housemates when we were
super young and um
they didn't take good care of their cats
so we had like a bad experience
with a cat but i don't know i love them
too as well
this
person we lived with
she had a the kitty box
in her broom
and in our shared bathroom too
and we would walk by our trunks
day after day and there were the [ __ ]
would just accumulate to the point where
there was [ __ ] outside the cat was just
[ __ ] on the floor
in her room yeah next to her bed
yeah i knew i needed a girl one i didn't
tell you this that she was so nasty she
didn't have a litter box she just would
throw the litter underneath her bed
one she would dump it under her bed she
she was so nasty she just took the
litter and just dumped it on her bed
what did it smell like
terrible how long did you date her for a
couple of days
once i i think that was one of the
things where i was like
so you were guys were being intimate and
you were smelly i went to your house one
time we made out right oh yeah what's
that smell she goes the litter box is
the
little down
she goes well it's not really a box i go
what is it there's no barrier she just
throw it
how is that easier than a box i don't
know why and she's so late and she must
like it
she just adds more litter she must like
it because the box is easier yeah she's
lazy
that's lazy
and nasty
is that lazy because a box is easier it
is yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're right yeah that's
pathological
yeah but then it's like if you don't
care that much about
that how are you maintaining your badge
oh yeah kitty litter's in the vag
yeah i mean yeah probably yeah you could
be yeah yeah it's everywhere else yeah
so i in my head i'm like and then when
somebody behaves like that you think
yourself because i i always like like
even with drug use right
you know i whenever i relapse i don't
get to the point where i lose my house
and my career right so i'm able to kind
of go yet
yet right but i'm able to kind of look
in the future and go if i continue this
behavior these are the things i'm going
to lose so i'm going to stop now yeah
right so in my head with that girl was
like if i continue this relationship
what else is
is going to be revealed to me
right that no that's because that's a
huge red flag no i don't know how she
maintains anything uh after you
discovered there's just a kitty litter
ocean
under her bed yeah we're good yeah but
no i'm very i'm very unhappy with my
physical health you know so i'm trying
thank you brother thank you because i
lost some weight i think you can tell
you're looking good you do look very
good you look very healthy yeah we've
been hiking together oh my goodness can
you do that at least
you don't like nature well
um
nature's okay yeah
he doesn't really like leaving the house
i would say well we have two young kids
three in three months
you know two dogs that are very that
don't like being separated from us you
have a third on the way
no no no you say no three month old
three months three years three and three
queens no no can i ask a question real
quick do you have a stroller
yes we do have a stroller sometimes when
we're on the hike we see people with
families with a stroller
can you do that or no
okay no
no so you're just gonna
know what my plan is to get on the right
food
get on the right medicine
start walking on doing the peloton i got
a treadmill start doing all that and
then
god willing
boom yeah you and i should have a
competition
well i mean what i have a little head
start but
i still want to lose a little okay well
he has this dream of becoming as ripped
as kumail
from kumail when he did the
the when he was a superhero and was it a
marvel movie
oh dude that was crazy you wanted to do
that once i thought it'd be just for the
content like but how great would it be
you and i got ripped
someone needs to cast you in a superhero
movie so you have a ch so you have a
reason to get like mega jacked or you
you and i have the resources just hear
me out okay
right you and i have the resources to
make our own movie
yeah about a jew and
a yeah this is the movie
we do it in two parts yeah like you know
how you know when they did when they did
cast away right obviously they didn't
shoot castaway in like a three-month
period right they waited right for him
to lose all that weight so he can play
the skinny version of themselves yeah
yeah so just hear me out right i can
already tell you're checked out no i'm
listening yeah yeah please listen to me
right now okay
so we do so it's basically two podcasts
that are fat yeah right real life right
and then i don't know what the script is
right but in somewhere in the movie you
and i are ripped
that maybe it's a duality how about this
you know how they do doctor strange
multiverse
right maybe there's a multiverse where
we're two fat dudes and we're also too
buffed we're like super happy right yeah
right and it's so weird
the portal opens and we have to cross
or something you know what i mean yeah
and then you're not gonna do it one more
like you
dude with down syndrome didn't finger
butthole
why what what isn't that your story
what'd you say
break it up again be clear
go ahead i'm just saying you know
alternatives are comfortable
you said down syndrome finger in my
butthole yeah he said in an alternate
universe we're all happy and healthy and
well adjusted yeah yeah and an alternate
universe
where a guy with down syndrome didn't
freak your butt
oh i see what you're saying yeah right
so in the buff version of the multiverse
right a guy would downstream didn't
finger my exactly
[Laughter]
okay
i wish this thing wasn't live
right
right
oh god
i'm sorry it's okay
so i guess you know anyone listening
right now um
if you're a script writer i'm gonna make
that happen right write that script you
do the work right if we did the work
though if we had so in a production
company and i just said
yeah yeah yeah you have to get buff for
the [ __ ] movie you would do it i'll
help fund were we paying for it no we'll
find it we'll find we'll finance we'll
find the money maybe ryan kavanagh yeah
right
right that would be a good way to men
ryan kavanagh if you're listening right
instead of the lawsuits why don't you
take that money right and put it into
this new project that ethan and i are
doing yeah yeah i mean and fat buff i
don't know how we call it yeah
loser winner yeah loser whatever the
movie is called right um that's the
movie because i i think that if we put
it into
you know i mean a project yeah maybe we
that would be the the motivation the
motivation and i think that you and i
will have a competition let's see how
buff we would get right and you and i
could get ripped bro it's it's pretty
incredible what uh pull up that picture
of uh what what's his name the guy who
had jacked for like the what was it the
marvel thing it was called
eternals yeah the eternals yeah yeah
yeah pull that up let's see
i can't believe how jack that guy got me
yeah he's like unreal
that guy's on steroids or something you
don't sound natural look at him yeah
look at that
but show them before show them before is
there a before and after or no
god look at that body because he looks
like a guy that's been jacked his whole
life yeah look at that bro that one on
the right yeah but look at the left
that's what that's when i knew him right
to the left have you met him since he'd
made that no
it's funny when you me you meet comics
and people like that and then they they
blow up you never see them again really
yeah yeah is he blowing up
yeah he's at a different level do you
think they're going to give me that
how do you do that
and then all of a sudden
um
the new sex and the city yeah i watched
the show yeah yeah but that's not gonna
blow me up no but i i it was fun to see
it i'm gonna do it again what is he
eating zoom in on that yeah yeah like
even his face got buff right yeah
all natural right here for sure
dude that guy [ __ ] he's injecting
steroids right into his dick bro yeah
what are you even eating looks like the
sausage from star wars
when he steals it from yoda oh yeah yeah
yeah
from lasagna reference wow
okay god bless so let's go let's do it
let's do it so we're gonna do that
but i don't know man you know what
what's your dream part to blow up to
this level
how do we get you there
i think i'm fine where i am
i think you're very successful yeah you
know for me it's like
this is gonna sound so cheesy but
i'll just say it um
i just i just feel like you know life is
just the way it is
first of all happen the way it's
supposed to happen things unfold the way
they're supposed to unfold don't force
it i don't want to control anything
because there's no way to do it right so
it's like i just accept it i do the best
i can
i show up the things right i walk
through fear i do all the things that
are necessary to become successful you
know i mean obviously the the only
difference between a guy like you and i
and the rest of the people is we bought
cameras we set up and we did it right
and i think you know when when people
online are going
they're not even fun like i've heard
people say
bobby lee's not even that funny or
whatever it might be right it's like
regardless of what you think it's like
you know you can do it yeah do it anyone
can do whatever they want you know my my
whole origin story
is i was watching jimmy kimmel it's so
stupid but i saw the man go you know
this was like like [ __ ] i don't know
20 years ago he's like in this day and
age all you got to do is buy a camera
and put yourself on youtube and if
you're funny people are going to find
you and you're going to make it it's not
like it used to be where there's all
these hurdles you know there's no people
do that
i was like [ __ ] that's true and so
that's what motivated me to buy a camera
and just uh
get out there and and do it yeah wait
did you let me i forget
had you guys met before you started are
you already doing it before
you guys met before yes and then when he
started to start
together
we made our channel together i was going
to art school and i had can i hit one of
those
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah they have great flavor that's even
the best flavor mochas
i just ran out of mocha do you do um
nicotine gum or
are you just were you a smoker
yeah
yeah to it's the health trifecta
yeah yeah he just quit i quit four
months ago so i um these have really
helped the nicotine gum's really good
for me oh yeah that helps as well great
yeah but the problem with nicotine i
chew it so i like these you and i are
very similar you know you and i are very
similar in many ways we always say that
yeah yeah yeah yeah but um
my penis is also three colors
is it
no it's pretty homemade homogeneous
it seems translucent is it
it's slightly see-through yeah yeah i
kind of like it's like one like
vietnamese spring rolls
yeah like can i look like can i see like
if i look you can see that and
everything but i can can i see like
heart beating you can see yeah
yeah i don't like that yeah yeah yeah i
don't like don't you like the spring you
can't see what the mechanism
inside you cannot see inside my penis
you know i've never seen his but i
assume andrew santino the guy do that oh
it's just see through that like you
because i look at his arm
i can see veins i'm not allowed i
shouldn't see right because he's so pale
yeah like right now look look look you
see one vein i'm not that pale yeah
right you're not no but like some white
dudes you see
like mechanisms and things that are
going on no there's nothing like that
yeah no yeah and it's okay you won't
right okay yeah like i've never seen a
vagina i'm saying to this but like if i
saw a vagina and i saw veins and
heartbeating whoa and things i don't
know if i would like that whoa
i like any kind of form
i like all form of attack
but eli you were saying something and i
cut you off i was just saying that we
when we
like before we started i was going to
art school and i had to take a video art
class and so i started um
i didn't want to be in front of the
camera so i started recording him and
that's how we started no the real reason
is that either was doing video art class
and this one guy she would do videos
with
that's not this is 100 for you okay as
she goes he's so cool he can do anything
she said we recorded something together
and he was cool okay she said literally
that yes i did because he could act and
for me it's like i could never so i was
just saying like he he just like we
started recording it wasn't just me it
was a group
and this guy like immediately started
acting so it's just like it was so cool
i said i said to myself [ __ ] that guy i
can do that [ __ ] i'm not impressed by
that yeah yeah
and so
i [ __ ] and i did and i am better than
him right yes thank you see well he is
he better looking i just yeah
he was that was part of the problem oh
yeah yeah
so then
but let me ask you something did you
i did not mean anything by it though was
it a hit right away or did it take time
i don't know the history for us it took
a long time
yeah so for us too we didn't make any
money for the beginning it took us a
long time is that how well you mean with
the podcast or valet yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know it's like a couple of
years in it it still didn't make a lot
of money and nothing that made it some
but it wasn't like a livable it wasn't a
livable thing you know i mean and i was
kind of like oh well i like doing that
yeah
yeah well that's good that you built on
that foundation
we were like we were just happy for
anything you know because it was like it
meant not working at a restaurant and
not working at some office so we were
like whatever we're making from this is
amazing well i had a day job i worked in
an office for five years and he was in
school just like marketing [ __ ]
and once we started making like three
thousand dollars a month we [ __ ] quit
our jobs at one thousand was it that is
it i mean i saved up a bit of money i
had like 20 thousand dollars saved or
something for working for five years
yeah so [ __ ] that we're making a
thousand dollars one thousand a month
and i started doing all kinds of little
things like
selling goodie bags that i was making
like with stickers and things for the
fans yeah or selling art all kinds of we
were hustlers always i think we're
hustlers too yeah yeah that's really
interesting i didn't know you guys had
like a slow start to tiger valley
because you were famous when you guys
started that no he wasn't in a very well
how long have you been doing tiger bells
uh seven
years seven years you've been famous
longer than that
yeah but it was you know when you're
when you're famous in one area which is
sketching live stand-up comedy right um
it doesn't translate right let you know
so it's like for me it's like for some
it does like um jack shepard
a translator you know anna ferris she's
killing it you know i mean jenna fischer
the list goes on but there are some
actors it doesn't okay right so
so
there needs to be uh there needed to be
a transition there but the thing is is
that for me
when i was on the road i would do radio
and that's why i kind of learned how to
especially open anthony i mean that was
where i learned to kind of be shocking
and
say
[ __ ] and make [ __ ] up and go crazy right
but um but what i'm impressed about you
guys especially you specifically
is and and this is a the dead honest
[ __ ] truth is is that
i think it was about eight or nine
months ago
you know one of my dogs chewed up
one of my beanies right
and there's a hole at the top of it but
i still wear it oh my gosh and so one
day i was just like how the [ __ ] do i
get more of this beanie
because this style is my favorite what
is teddy fresh
and then she goes oh that's uh gila and
ethan's company h3 and i go
is it more your company
yeah it's your company
and there was a
like number one it was i was like
because that's the
the the fit
it didn't seem like you know sometimes
like even with my products on um
bad friends or tiger belly you know it
seems like the run of the mill
places where you could everyone gets
theirs or whatever but with years it
looked like a specific even the fabric
and the color was like a very specific
thing style wise so i'm like even that
[ __ ] thing you're wearing so i'm just
so [ __ ] envious of it well you know
we workshop that beanie for a while
because the beanie is very important to
us yeah so you get the fit specifically
right yeah yeah you've choose the fabric
and stuff oh so you did all that yeah we
have a team i do everything i have i
have a long a big team now like the
company has gotten pretty big but i do
everything i'm involved in we have over
40 employees there really yeah yeah i
would have always wanted to start a
tiger belly clothing line mm-hmm yeah i
mean it's a lot of work though it is it
seems like it yeah but even like the
colors and that style and it just
everything pops the thing is we
manufacture and design everything
ourselves like a traditional streetwear
brand
so
it's hard one way you could do it is
there's like agents
third party agents that can
like design stuff and work with
manufacturers white labels i think they
call them private labels yeah or private
labels yeah i want to do a cologne
called bird's glue
that's power button right so it's
basically it's my own cologne and i want
the bottle to look like a bird but sick
right right and i want the smell to be
not bad like it's going to smell like i
don't know what bird blue smells like
probably not good it's not good
but um i want it to be
very specific like almost lychee
oak wood oh that sounds nice like a
woodsy
melon
like really dark wood though yeah he's a
really big scent guy
for life his palette is very advanced
like he's interesting he doesn't like
scents that are expected he likes to
smell what is it like a greek church is
what you said yeah
a greek church
but also like blade runner you know what
i mean like he like no like blade no no
no no no no no like blade runner the new
blade the new blade how it smells right
you know how like ryan gosling goes to
you know i mean it's all done the worm
farm yeah you know what i mean okay wow
what that smells like not the city smell
that one smell like piss and [ __ ] right
but more like when he you know when he
got what's his name the um the um guy
from galaxy that you like the filipino
dude dave batista oh yeah red deep tista
and they fight you know what i mean and
he has the worm farm right
not in that um building but like outside
what what that would smell interesting
yeah yeah yeah thank you
yeah but i want yeah i mean or like what
i also like is gothic forest
you know i mean like um you know like
the witch
i mean edgar's movie yeah where it's
spooky yeah that that's what see that
tree there's some oh that tree has an
interesting thing now imagine billy
eilish
ran by that tree she's wearing something
right but then you get the worm and the
atmosphere
as well you should make up yeah you're
back
not gross we could work we have we have
vendors we could make a scent for you oh
really probably right yeah i can do
private labels it takes a long time to
do stuff like when we do this it takes
like a year to develop a product we work
a year in advance like right now i am
design i'm finishing designing q1 of
2023 and then i'm going to start q2 so
that means um april may june should we
make a slide for bobby can we go i want
a little profit from it of course yeah
can we do 50 50 on it right but it's
three just like here yeah it's through
you guys yeah bobby lee's new scent bird
flu
right
what's so funny
well it has a funny name but yeah bird
flu or sars it's got to be one of those
stars yeah yeah bird flu is better yeah
yeah bird flu is better right yeah i'd
like i'd caution you though he doesn't
like scents that smell good he doesn't
want to be like he likes scents that are
interesting
he he doesn't like it when people are
like oh you smell good he likes it and
people are like what is that yeah a
little good a little good yeah i want
the right people to go you know what i
mean interesting like okay
so um there's a company called madeworn
right
and i was there at the you know they
they're they're a high-end
t-shirt factory where they make old
vintage uh rock tees right
and i was there at their studio once
and i go what's that it was on the table
and they go it's our cologne but it's
not really working right it's not
working yeah and i go and i read it it's
called smoke
it was just called smoke right and i
smelt it and it it made me do this on my
face
right and i go can i have it
and i
oh my god right and then one day
a cool guy came up to me and he smelled
and most people comics were like
right right but this cool guy that guy i
respect
goes what is that man that's amazing
whoa
that's what i'm looking for so bird flu
is gonna be like that
every once in a while people will go i
like that
right but most powerful you know i i
don't know if you watched seinfeld beach
was uh
yeah beach smell was what kramer
workshopped oh really yeah so can you
get that online
no you haven't watched seinfeld have you
i'm outing you no fake comedian
why i'm just kidding
what does that mean
it's just
it's nothing well once he went to you i
don't think you're a fake community i'm
just kidding you don't have to like
starting off what is the finger free
butthole i don't know what does finger
free buttholes mean
an alternate oh
where you didn't get fingered in the
butthole
that's great is that ethan
yeah yeah oh and yeah it is you yeah
yeah that's the movie finger-free that's
a that's a lot of pressure that those
bodies
would have to choose if he can do it we
can do it
but we would have to get on the juice i
think oh yeah well he's on juice i'm
telling you that guy juices
bro what the [ __ ]
don't accuse
i don't know if he's juicing but i'm
just looking at him not cancer got
juiced right who's not cancer the writer
the guy right there lance yeah oh you
have not cancer yes blood doping yeah is
that not
a brunch um with you know it was a
seinfeld well i'm sorry it was a jer
okay
so
the reason that
seinfeld is a sore spot for him
he went to a brunch with judd apatow
and it was a brunch with seinfeld and
other people he was very nice he was
super nice was very nice but his um wife
called him robbie or something when it
was robbie no he called she got me billy
lee billy lee for like the whole
afternoon is everything fine billy yeah
correct
and i just cut i don't like to correct
people
but then your heart you're harboring
a resentment i know i like to harbor
make it turn into a thing but like you
know me inside my body it's going to
have to correct someone about your name
yeah yeah i hate doing that if it was a
fan
if you're gonna hold on to this
resentment
he's not he's avoiding watching seinfeld
because i've had people come up hey
tommy lee like do i look like [ __ ]
tommylee [ __ ]
you know the hair thank you right in
terms of the body no it's bobby oh
i'll correct that yeah right but when it
comes to like a high-end i had to wear a
nice thing i wore my favorite hawaiian
shirt and it was everyone michael
richards everyone was there right it was
during the day it was at the palm you
know restaurant in west hollywood i
didn't belong right you know what i mean
i think it was the first and last time
judd abbott ever invited me to anything
you do belong i do belong i know and i
showed up there and i was trying to be
very mindful and cordial and yeah you
know i i'm i want to be a part of it
and so when she goes billy did you guys
i liked it it was nice
right but i didn't correct her that's
all and i do you know it's like
here's what i do what's up
i don't like comedy elitists okay do you
think jerry's a comedy leader that's not
what i said i think that's what you're
into that's not what i'm saying i'm just
saying even the illusion of it
i don't like it no jerry i think jerry
would say he's a comedy elitist he does
the suit he goes it's a joke as a
punchline and every word needs to be
crafted exactly that's yeah that's his
style
i've never been into it and i i don't
like people that like comedy elitists
you know um i have ptsd from certain
things that i'll watch on tv that can't
watch
because it reminds me of um
this kind of harvard yale where comedy
riders were interesting you know i mean
we're uppity and you're you get [ __ ] you
had bad experiences with these concerts
yeah i mean it's like you know you tell
fart jokes you mean you show your penis
on stage whatever you're doing
this is not my it's not as good but it's
like but it's not it's low brow
it's bottom of the barrel entertainment
and there's you know there's definitely
you know a group out there who i am
friends with that i'm a part of they
invite me to do their shows and this and
that but and i'm trying to be more um
because i i think most of it's in my
head it's got to be in my head it's in
my opinion
right and so it's like it's not real
yeah so i um but it's sometimes i
perceive it to be
but then i'm in
some situations that are very elitist
i did a movie last summer that had huge
stars in it and i was a part of it and i
was you know in high class you know
dinner situations and i've been in
situations where
definitely i'm you know i mean in an
elite situation yeah right yeah but i
think growing up in comedy early on
and let's go back to the bullying right
and because of the you know i used to be
paulie shore and carlos mencia and
andrew dice clay's opener
back in the 90s right i
was exposed to really difficult
immune infertive audiences too like
sometimes you know i mean carlos would
go hey let's we're playing a tortilla
factory in houston
right and i just go out yeah a tough
crowd you know i mean one time he i did
oh i did an opening show where it was
like
no one spoke english
right and he goes that's outdoor it was
like a you know i mean a mexican
festival yeah and i ate it like i was
just exposed to really difficult
situations
and um i never did you know i mean
i now do it now but like largo or any of
these kind of places because i've always
even now i get invited to like these hot
you know kuwaiti 20 places and i'm a
little
hesitant of doing it you know i think it
is in your head i think you're very well
respected
and i don't think your company's low
brow i think you're you have a very
refined act you're very good at what you
do yeah thank you and i don't think you
should feel insecure about being in the
cr and uh in their club you know thank
you also the good thing about being a
comedian
is like
it's great what i like what i like about
doing my job
what no i was gonna say it's creative
it's you you get a pass for being like
whatever it is that you are that's what
i'm you are the reason you're famous is
because you're a [ __ ] degenerate
so if you go to a meeting they're not
going to expect bobby lee the
professional in a suit
they're they're hiring you because of
who you are so if i show up to a [ __ ]
business meeting and in sandals and
shorts and i'm [ __ ] crass or whatever
that's who i am
that's that's who they're hired you know
what i mean you should
be be yourself all the time because
that's [ __ ] your job you know what
i'm so glad i came here thank you
because i'm learning so much about no
let's be real yeah okay
let's be real for a second okay ignoring
the first half no even now okay right
okay good
you know there's going to be fallout
yeah um wait can we talk about what we
think the fallout let's guess
can this time can they call me instead
of you
[Laughter]
yeah
if you guys have a problem
if you guys have a problem with anything
i've said i'll take this
let me ask
your podcast brandon yeah no you would
never i have no association no i
wouldn't i want to ask him why
not i don't like the whole alpha male
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't like that whole bravado
because when they said i was a [ __ ]
that i'm weak i'm not into that
right it's like
that's als also not [ __ ] true bro
it's pathetic strong
no that whole that whole culture of like
meathead alpha male [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] with that at all so i it's
just i don't that whole thing doesn't
appeal to me yeah
like i had crystal on many times yeah
and i don't think he falls into that i
don't think
i don't think he does he's his own thing
no and i've had a lot of comedians on a
lot of your friends and stuff but i
never [ __ ] with that whole meathead
side of the yeah of the la podcast scene
yeah they're like i'm going to talk
about dalia a second there is a um
a very like kind of like
child-like
kindred thing that he has that i have
with him
i see parts of a playful very innocent
you know side to him you know i mean
that iva was always locked into even
when um you know i was on mad tv and
when i met him i had already kind of had
a name when i met him
he was just an open miker there was
already just an immediate like because
it you know when you look at him in
stature he's kind of a
tall kind yeah he's like yeah he works
out his body you know
but he instantly we had this like we're
kids you know i mean
and i um i felt like i've known them all
my life you know i mean so i don't put
them in that
no not at all
not at all yeah yeah yeah she taught me
huh so you guys you wanted
so you you wanted to no maybe you wanted
to she tapped me with her foot so you
you wanted to guess about the fallout
you seemed like you wanted to do that
yeah i i want to ask bobby what he
thinks is going to happen from here on
out
i'm going to tell you exactly what's
going to happen
am i not close enough to the mic
is there something that i'm doing wrong
no you are thank you very much
just lean back a little bit or even this
way
you're not in frame
look you can look at yourself
so what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen is um i'll just tell
you what i'm gonna do okay
going to leave here right i'm going to
grab my box of peonies do you have that
set up
yeah we got that okay good right and i'm
going to be very cordial i know no i had
a good time and i want to hug and we're
going to do all that right
i'm going to get in the car and i'm
going to look at her and i go what the
[ __ ] okay
right and she's gonna go it's gonna be
fine i'm gonna call him or whatever
right and i don't know if you're gonna
call him or not i probably will i think
you should no i i have
no problem calling him letting him know
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to um
um
at that point i don't know what's going
to happen because i don't know what the
reaction because this is live so i'm
pretty sure he's getting he knows i'm
sure he knows that yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm afraid i'm glad i turned my phone
off because
there might be taxes right but i really
like what you said earlier like when you
know the truth
nothing else matters and i think that
um even though there is going to be
fallout about this the truth is simply
the truth and we shouldn't be running
away from that that is just what
happened and i think if he were in front
of us today he'd probably agree yeah
that is what happened
i don't think so i think he's in denial
but but no but the truth is he
threatened you behind the scenes he's
clearly not looking to have a
uh i think these guys specifically are
very afraid of getting cancelled
obviously they've seen the effect it can
have on people very close to them krista
leah
was brutally
canceled as we all know i mean it's not
secret and he's close with him they have
a podcast together right
so i'm just agree that's me yeah i don't
know yeah so so i'm just saying i think
that
he thinks the way he perceives it is
you're probably trying to
like chris deleo him or destroy him
which i which obviously clearly you guys
aren't trying to do i mean the
accusations didn't even rise to anything
like that
yeah it's not so i think he perceives it
as like an existential threat
which is why he reacted so strongly it's
of his making he did those things it's
not even that it's like i forgave him
for those things
right i forgave him i i looked i talked
to him on the phone i mean not look them
in the eyes but i talked to him i go
listen i hold no grudges right
you did what you did right
and in response to the way he called you
and bullied you no before that
in response to him oh that he hit on you
yeah yeah right yeah i'm fine with it
even when it happened i was fine with it
i i understood it she's hot i get it
yeah yeah yeah right so it's like um
that's that right and let me say this
too fyi
i think other guys would not have
responded that way
right but i've always been like i know
how this whole game is right and i'm
like you know what he didn't have sex
with her right
um i'm fine right and i want to continue
doing my business yeah right um
my only concern is because i feel like
there's some unhinged elements
right
and um you know
i don't know what the retaliation is
because
even though i did nothing wrong and i
don't even know what the [ __ ] is going
on right
i still feel like there's going to be
retaliation in a weird way right let me
let me try to guess put myself in his
mind because i dealt with this kind of
[ __ ]
not that specific issue
my my guess is just icy cold
ignore it's going to happen he's going
to ignore it no because he doesn't want
it out there he's not going to talk
about it publicly or does it make him
look bad he just no but he's not going
to acknowledge it because then his fans
are going to see it and be like oh
what's this about because it makes him
look like a giant [ __ ] in both
accounts what he did then and what he
did now so he's going to ignore it it's
going to be icy cold i agree you're not
going to hear from him that's my guess
okay
but what happens
if the vice versa if you see him though
and he is kind of unhinged does he drink
i don't know we don't i don't know
anything yeah so if you run it i
wouldn't want to run into him
necessarily because again he's got that
meat head thing
you know you know what's sad about the
whole thing is i just want to say and
and you may
bawk at me people on the internet are
listening right now but i i honestly
i i don't have a problem with them
yeah i never have yeah i never will the
only problem i have is being accused of
things that i have nothing to do with
and threatening bullied and both right
yeah black and saying that i'm weak and
all that stuff right and that i'm the
mastermind behind you know i mean you
know i mean his woes right i don't think
about them ever
they're not even in my wheelhouse of
thoughts i have so many other really
really
personal things going on right that i'm
dealing with in my own that has nothing
to do with show business or anything
right yeah i'm i'm in therapy i'm in you
know i mean i had just recently relapsed
i'm i have 90 over 90 days sober you
know i mean i'm doing my i have my own
[ __ ] that i'm dealing with yeah
you know um i have other career things
that i'm really excited about you know i
mean yeah you know theo and i have a
project at fox that's awesome right um i
have a project at nbc right i um
you know sex in the city wants to [ __ ]
with me more you know i'm doing
reservations i'm doing other things
that um i'm excited about that i'm
focused on right i have an animation
show that i'm working on with titmouse
you know what i mean and there's all
these things that i'm doing and it's
like you know
i don't think about you guys i'm doing
my own thing man but it's like i'm being
pulled into a [ __ ] war yeah right
that i don't want to be in and and
i'm going to tell you what's going to
happen i know because i know their
mentality i know they want to protect
themselves and the way they want to
protect themselves is through
intimidation right and through threats
and through revenge
right and that's why when you're [ __ ]
with people
that are
sometimes unhinged
my fear is is that i don't know what the
results are going to be right because i
don't want anything to do with it i want
it squashed i want to [ __ ] move
forward and i want to live my [ __ ]
life right and at this point i don't
think that's what's going to happen man
i think you're wrong bro
i don't know what they can do because
you guys put all the cards on the table
but i guess yeah i don't know
but at the end of the day like
if everyone just didn't talk if he was
like you know what i'm done i'm not
talking about it you guys said you know
what i'm done i'm not talking about
everyone would be fine that's what they
don't understand i don't know why they
see this as such an existential threat
like everyone would be fine just go do
your own thing don't [ __ ] talk about
each other yeah and like but i don't
think they see it that way but i don't
think like
what you even said he did which is hit
on you when you had a when you're in a
relationship was like
career are people are going watching
yeah definitely did you tell about
numbers i don't even know how this works
what are they saying the chat is very
supportive of you guys yeah yeah yeah
yeah people love it i can tell it's a
great great show okay yeah
it's really hard it's been honestly can
i be honest with you i'm sorry
no i love it why not you know what i
mean
why did you do it okay
no um
this has been the most interesting
podcast i've ever done
yeah i thought it was fantastic that was
fantastic fantastic i mean um
yeah it's been i've never felt
the kind of emotions that i felt
fear but also relief
in combination with um
an unknown you know i mean aspect of it
you know it's like we've talked about
even aside from that about
our weight doing the butthole thing
star trek and on and on but i'll be
honest with you the whole time i've been
thinking about
that thing
the whole time in the first half yeah
it's been literally of course lingering
of course in the back of my mind
the whole [ __ ] time
because um
i don't do well with ptsd
and trauma you have a lot of it
because
that's kind of
you're not you don't hide that you're
open about
a lot of the stuff you've been through
and especially considering all that it's
even more [ __ ] up the way they came at
you like that it's just it's just [ __ ]
that's why people like him do that right
because not a lot of people will stand
up and
or wanna even go there you know a lot
nobody
wants to go through that
so
he's doing it to silence you and there
is also something very slanderous
happening was that he didn't just tell
us about the reddit thing he was telling
rogan he was telling whitney he would
believe that though it seems insane who
knows but
he's saying he's telling people he's
telling other people that this is what
you did this is what our company did and
that is to me like
well i mean his name when they did
assault me right
you know
his name came up a lot rogan
yeah you know i mean
as a threat like we're going to go to
rogan
daddy road
right stupid and so when they use him
especially because i'd obviously love
him yeah joe and i um i don't have any
issues with him and
in fact i just saw him three weeks ago
i love him we hug and we talk and he's
just been so supportive of me joe but
when they use him right um
as a threat it's kind of like because he
has such a big audience right and it's
like i don't know what do you think joe
is that stupid though that people can
tell him yo you're not gonna have bobby
on right i don't think joe you think he
got to where he got because he would
listen to stuff like that but the fact
that they go there the fact that they go
there says a lot about them yeah it
doesn't say anything about joe yeah but
youth but you know
we when we first moved here to la
uh from israel we had all kinds of [ __ ]
happen to us and we had people tell us
like we're gonna put you on a blacklist
nobody's ever gonna work with you all
kind of [ __ ] like that that was
really scary at the time and i cried and
all this stuff and guess what nothing
happened oh it was a youtube mcn this is
the biggest [ __ ] real nothing nothing
happened of course
very successful
well you know what i did the minute they
started threatening i went public with
everything [ __ ] clowned them into
[ __ ] the ceo called me because they
were [ __ ] us over business-wise like
we signed up they said it was one way
they made it they we signed up with them
and locked in a contract there was
another way so i said listen let's just
part ways it's not working and they say
they go you signed a contract it's time
to stop being a child that's not how it
works he's like i'm gonna tell everyone
you're bad to work with
and i found out later that he was
telling other big youtubers not to work
with me and [ __ ]
wow yeah
and so i just put them all on i put
everything out there
and
they [ __ ] ate [ __ ] because they're
pieces of [ __ ]
and we got out of the contract the
reality is
none of it really matters it does
nothing this is not going they have zero
power over your career absolutely zero
they have minus power but here's where
and this is
this is the truth
is
the reason why i'm scared
is because i'm afraid of losing certain
things
but the thing is is that
i'm getting to a place in my life
where because i honestly for the last 25
years
show business and my career was so
important to me because i worked so hard
at it right
um but
i've exp i've been trying to expand my
life outside of it and to go what do i
love what else do i love what else can i
do right and once i let go of the fact
that this could go away or you know i
mean it doesn't make me who i am right
and that there are other things that i
can do and other loves it'll be painful
right but um in that regard um
i'm fine i i give it too much power but
you know what the truth is
that maybe you're too
in your head to realize
you're bobby lee dude
you're a legend bro you already made it
yeah nobody's gonna take anything away
from you at this point yeah yeah you
don't have to care about any of those
[ __ ] guys yeah you don't compare [ __ ]
because the job is gonna come the fans
are there people are gonna buy tickets
your shows because you're [ __ ] bobby
lee yeah and you're already a legend
yeah you've already uh
you're already
built yourself you don't have to care
about anything anymore
you [ __ ] already made it nothing can
take it away from you anymore
you've ascended you don't have to worry
about all the showbiz game and [ __ ] you
know what i mean ascension yeah
excellent you you already ascend you
ascended dude i ascended right yeah god
man
thank you you're impervious i'm
improving impregnable oh
thanks man yeah
and basically just don't like uh
r-word anyone and you'll be good oh what
yeah that's good do what just don't like
just don't like trap girls in a room and
show them your dick like louis c.k did
or something
and you're good i don't i don't do stuff
like that yeah so you're getting it yeah
yeah how long does how long have we gone
it's been three hours two
hours 23 minutes how long does it go oh
well however we want how long you want
are we good i think we're good because i
i want to be able to um
get my beanies
and i want to be able to process um all
this stuff in the car when we have lunch
i haven't eaten all day
and um
we'll come back and we'll give i'll give
you the um
update update yeah i'll be fine i'll
give them money but you know what i'll
give them your number
i'm a big fan i'm a big fan of yours too
i'm a big admirer of both i've always
loved you man and you both of you i love
you i love the show that you've branched
out to doing your own thing it's cool
love tiger belly thank you it's trash
tuesday it's your shoe show to give it a
shout out tuesday and you guys have to
come on at something yeah sure we'd love
to have you yeah yeah i'm just now
starting to get back to doing things
because you know the baby baby yeah it
also would help us as well
i would love you guys to be just invite
us and i'll come okay come on we'll be
there and help us as well we'll be there
okay
thank you for having us on thank you i
really love you both i love you you are
you are legend yeah you're untouchable
you made it dude
[Music]
[Applause]
all right thanks guys
happy friday
be on monday
back wife what you gonna do with me then
you know and the whole damn crew goose
and gaps with all the guests you'll see
the best podcasts in the world take it
from me jc over j hp baby we podcast now
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three